mission of the Orion Space Capsule. Artemis 2 will be the first time we put
humans on this rocket. We're going back to the moon because it's the next step
in our journey to Mars. We were always going to the moon. Pushing ourselves to
explore is just core to who we are. That's a part of being a human.
Continuing to test out every bit of Orion. Coming back to Earth seven miles
seven miles a second, and humanity sets big goals. We can bring together genius from around the world.
You have the best people on planet earth putting this vehicle together
to innovate for the benefit of humanity and to inspire the world through discovery.
Welcome to Artemis Mission Control here at Johnson Space Center in Houston, Texas. I'm Leah Cheshire
Mustachio. Right now the Artemis 2 crew and Mission Control are preparing to support today's
lunar flyby, the first time we've sent humans around the moon in over 50 years.
Integrity, you can use the OEs and your HHP camera for the milestone words
at the Apollo 13 record distance.
You'll notice that we pause every time we hear communications to and from the crew.
They are the stars for today.
This afternoon, the crew will have their closest approach of the moon
and will surpass the record, that record just mentioned, of the furthest humans have ever flown,
set by the Apollo 13 astronauts in 1970.
You're looking at a live view inside the Orion spacecraft
and at our Artemis II crew members.
They have just completed their post-sleep period during
which they conduct any hygiene and cabin setup for the day.
They also had a chance to eat breakfast before we got
into our daily planning conference.
The flight control team here
in Mission Control Houston collecting information
from all consoles around the room that we could relay
up to the crew ahead of this monumental day.
As you can see on your right, NASA astronaut Christina Koch taking a video of NASA astronaut
Victor Glover.
We expect to have great views of the crew throughout the day as well as, of course,
the moon.
We expect to surpass that Apollo distance record in 55 minutes and 50 seconds.
We are now looking live at a camera mounted on one of the spacecraft's solar arrays pointed
to our lunar neighbor.
We are currently just 14,200 miles away from the moon and 247,672 miles away from planet Earth.
Houston, Integrity for AGA.
Ready to copy.
Carbon dioxide 2.3. Oxygen, which has the alarm, 26.3. 73.1 degrees. 10.3 PSI. And one follow-on question.
We understand milestone words will be directly following the conference.
Will that take the place of the PAO event, or will the PAO events still take place?
Good question, Christina.
The milestone words that we exchange at the record distance at the end of the conference
will take the place the PAO-timelined activity, so that'll be our moment to talk about this
occasion and after that there will be no more expected PAO words and you can get
straight into your flyby. Copy all AGA. Even though it's taking the place of it
it will all just be on OE1 with HHP camera, no additional video. Is that right?
Affirm. Okay, thank you. Yep, some of us had already heard that. Sorry about that. Talk to you soon. No problem.
Those communications between NASA astronaut Christina Koch and Canadian
Space Agency astronaut and today's CAPCOM or capsule communicator the one
person here speaking with the crew right now that is Jenny Gibbons she is an
Artemis 2 backup crew member here in Mission Control Houston we are now four
days 18 hours and 30 minutes into the flight of Orion for Artemis 2 the
Artemis 2 crew inside Orion lifted off atop the Space Launch System rocket on
Wednesday April 1st from NASA's Kennedy Space Center in Florida those four crew
crew members are the first to live and work inside the Orion spacecraft, which they have
named Integrity, and have been busy conducting meticulously-timelined events.
It was a beautiful ascent from Kennedy Space Center.
One of those early events was the proximity operations demonstration during which NASA
astronaut Victor Glover, the Artemis II pilot, manually flew Orion after having just detached
from the interim cryogenic propulsion stage as if they intended to dock.
This was practice for future Artemis missions during which astronauts in Orion will dock
with the lunar lander that will take them to the surface of the moon.
About 24 hours after launch, 25 hours actually, Orion then conducted TLI, the Trans Lunar
Injection Burn.
This 5 minute 50 second burn committed Orion to departing high Earth orbit and set us up
for today's flyby.
That Trans Lunar Injection burn also served as the spacecraft's de-orbit burn.
It slingshots Orion around the moon and sends the crew on a free-return trajectory, with
splashdown approximately 7.07 p.m. Central on Friday, April 10.
Last night on flight day five, the crew entered the lunar sphere of influence, the point at
which the pull of the moon's gravity will become stronger than the pull of Earth's.
We've also been getting some great views inside the cabin of the crew members living daily
life from working out to eating, taking photos and making memories together.
They've also been taking some beautiful views of our home planet and of the moon.
And we expect many, many more of those following today's activities.
These live views back inside the cabin of Orion.
But before we get into fly-by, let's take a minute to get reacquainted with our crew.
Reid Wiseman is the Artemis II commander and a Baltimore native.
He's been in space once before.
I think there was going to be some...
Absolutely.
And that was the voice of Reid Wiseman.
He has been in space Once before as a flight engineer.
If they don't come, you can just lie to us and tell us that they're there.
We'll keep that in mind, too.
And he...
I'm sure they'll be here.
Wiseman also has a great sense of humor.
He was aboard the International Space Station from May through November 2014 as part
of Expedition 41.
This was a 165-day mission during which he and his crewmates completed more
than 300 science experiments in areas like human physiology, medicine, science,
earth science and astrophysics.
They set a milestone for station science by completing a record 82 research hours
in a single week he also served as chief of nasa's astronaut office from december 2020 to november
2022 and here on earth he has two daughters the artemis ii pilot is victor glover selected as an
astronaut in 2013 when at the time he was serving as a legislative fellow in the united states
senate his first trip to space was in november 2020 when he launched as a pilot of nasa spacex
Crew-1 mission. That was the first operational mission of NASA's commercial crew program,
which resumed launching American rockets from American soil to the International Space Station
since the end of the shuttle program. Victor is a U.S. Navy captain and naval aviator who
served as a test pilot, racking up more than 3,500 flight hours in more than 40 different aircraft.
He also became the first person to pilot Orion the other day when we saw the
PROX OPS demonstration shortly after launch. He and his wife have four children.
Mission Specialist Christina Koch is a native of Grand Rapids, Michigan.
She was selected to the Astronaut Corps in 2013, the same class as Victor Glover.
She served as flight engineer on the International Space Station from March 2019 to February 2020.
During that time, Cook set a record for the longest single spaceflight by a woman with a total
of 328 consecutive days in space.
She also participated in the first ever all-female spacewalk
with her friend and colleague, Jessica Meir, now living
and working aboard the International Space Station
yet again.
Before becoming an astronaut,
Christina helped build space science instruments
and led scientific field work in some
of the most remote environments on the planet.
Her hobbies include surfing, rock climbing, community service,
yoga, travel, and photography.
And she is certainly getting a chance to do that.
First-time flyer, Canadian Space Agency astronaut Jeremy Hansen is flying to the moon as a mission
specialist on the Artemis II mission.
The London, Ontario native was selected as an astronaut in 2009.
After that, he worked as CAPCOM at NASA's Mission Control Center here in Houston.
CAPCOM stands for Capsule Communicator and is the single direct voice communicating with
the astronauts in space.
He also participated in training exercises like living on the ocean floor off the coast
of Florida to simulate deep space exploration for seven days.
In 2017, he became the first Canadian to lead a NASA astronaut class, and he also enjoys
getting out on a sailboat, rock climbing, and mountain biking.
And he and his wife have three children.
As you can see, the crew members have dimmed the cabin lights inside Orion.
As they prepare for their lunar flyby, they'll be configuring the cabin as they'd like to
have it to allow for proper positioning as they move about to and from the windows, taking
photos of the Moon.
Dimming the lights also helps prevent reflections from inside Orion onto the windows.
Ahead of this lunar flyby, let's dive in and explain what you can expect over the next
several hours.
The crew has about six hours allotted to make observations about the Moon.
Throughout the flyby, their activities have been precisely timelined.
There are five blocks of time during which the crew will be observing the Moon from Orion's
windows.
At any time, two members will be at the windows working in a pair.
One crew member will be taking photos from Window 2 with a blue shroud over the window.
This can help prevent that glare or reflection from inside Orion.
They have an 80 to 400 millimeter zoom lens to use.
The other astronaut will be in Window 3 using their portable computing device, you'll hear
that referred to as PCD, to make annotations.
Both of these crew members will make audio recordings of what they are seeing, and they'll
headsets connected to those PCDs. Those audio recordings will be sent to the
science team at a later date. We will not hear them live. The two crew members at
the windows will swap roles and positions halfway through their
timelined block. The other two crew members who won't be at the windows at
that time will be serving in the background as support. One will be
conducting the science set reps or situation reports. This is what we will
hear live from the crew. They'll be calling down a few times each hour to
discuss what they are observing. Those situation reports include how the crew
is positioned, any missed targets or anything unexpected they saw, lunar
target descriptions, any hardware issues and of course their emotions and
reactions as they fly by the moon. The other support crew member will take
pictures of the astronauts at the windows and serve as camera support
providing new SD cards when needed. There's a 15-minute time frame between
each observation block during which the two support members switch places with
the crew making observations.
Two views, both coming from Orion.
There on the left, the inside of the spacecraft, and on the right, a view of our moon, the
destination for today.
During the lunar flyby today, Orion will provide astronauts with a full-disc view of the lunar
surface.
They'll have a higher vantage point, much farther than Apollo's lunar orbits on average.
These astronauts can observe both the holes and large-scale geologic features in a single
view.
And due to our April 1st launch date and current illumination conditions, the Artemis 2 astronauts
have become the first humans to directly observe certain far-side regions of the Moon with unaided eyes.
We are now 36 minutes until we see the Integrity crew pass the Apollo 13 distance record.
And joining me on console, I have Julianne Gross, the Artemiscuration lead.
joining me today thanks for having me i'm very excited to be here we're very excited to have you
so can you tell me about your role as artemis create artemis curation lead and what that entails
yeah so for the overall artemis campaign i'm the artemis um lunar sample curation lead that means
i'm helping artem i'm helping nasa to return the next set of lunar samples from the lunar surface
and for artemis ii specifically i'm one of the science theme leads and specifically i'm
I'm responsible or the voice for impacts of poles and landing sites fascinating
so how what helped us select the targets that the crew is going to be
photographing today so we had a plan coming in where we basically made a list
of all the available targets during the April launch window because before you
launch we wouldn't exactly be sure of which targets would be visible and so
once we launched we then were able to cut down on that list and prioritize our
targets and the five theme leads came together and really discussed and
collaborative talked through which which targets we could then which targets we
could then see and prioritize and so that made it into our plan we work then
with timeline to make sure that all the targets visible some targets are time
dependent like or set or earth rise and some targets will rotate out of view
when integrity starts going around the moon and so we have we put these in
early so that the crew has a chance to describe those to us fascinating I
cannot wait to hear what they have to say so we just heard them say that their
long lens is configured that's very exciting and for us when we look at the
moon from Earth what features are we seeing that the crew will also fly by
today yeah so I really hope that people on Earth who are in in nighttime will
look up into the moon tonight. The features that the crew will see that we can also currently
see are as dark as Plateau. Grimaldi is another feature. They're going to be sort of on our
limb. And then Oceanus Procolarum, that really dark, large area on the near side that we
can see. The crew is going to see that in the beginning. The more they fly around, the
less of that they will see. So those are targets we will hear them describe early on in the
flyby.
fascinating well and the crew has been training for years for this day and so we're going to hear
them make a lot of calls about what they are seeing on the moon and they're going to use
a lot of interesting terms that i myself need some brushing up on so could you walk us through
a few of the things that we'll hear them use to describe the moon like albedo exosphere
ejecta just some of those major terms we expect to hear from the crew yeah of course albedo is
basically a term of a reflectiveness of the surface and so high albedo usually
for the moon means bright areas and low albedo means like darker areas and so
when you look into the night sky you can see the the high albedos are the
white parts and the low albedos ones are the darker areas. Ejecta is when you
have an impact and it ejects or throws out material that then ends up on the
surface and you can see that as sort of race or race system so you might hear
them describe oh I can see ohm for example with its race it has an
asymmetric race coming out and so we are excited to hear them describe that you
might hopefully hear stuff about color or color hues and so if there's can see
any changes in those color hues from like white to gray to maybe brownish
we're excited to be here about that. Axosphere is the almost no existing
atmosphere of the moon, it's barely there but there is dust on the lunar surface
that can get lofted up through electrostatic forces and when the Sun
goes behind the moon it can scatter forward on those dust particles and sort
of like create a little glow on the horizon and so we're really excited to
see if the crew can actually see that this is so exciting thank you so much
for walking through all of that with us Julian gross Artemis curation lead we
really appreciate you joining us here today and good luck to your team thank
you I'm really excited to be here we are now MET four days 18 hours and 49
minutes into the flight of Orion this view of the moon from the Orion
spacecraft as we get closer and closer we're live here in Artemis mission
control at Johnson Space Center in Houston Texas just about 32 minutes away
until the crew surpasses the record set by Apollo 13 as the farthest astronauts
to ever leave Earth. This view coming from a camera mounted on the tip of one
of Orion's four solar arrays. Each array has a camera on its tip and so we
anticipate getting views throughout the lunar flyby. Of course except during the
point of loss of signal when the spacecraft flies behind the moon. Inside
Inside the cabin, the crew are configuring the inside of Orion for today's flyby, making
sure they have everything just where they want it to help them take the pictures that
they are aiming for for the science team here on the ground.
Coming up in just a few minutes, we will have a pre-lunar flyby conference.
During that lunar flyby science crew conference, our science officer here on console, Kelsey
young will be speaking directly with the crew members about their targets about
their goals for today what they expect to see and what we are hoping to hear
from them we have a lot of milestones coming up today so make sure you don't
miss them the first coming up again at 1 56 p.m. Eastern Time the crew will pass
the distance from Earth record set by Apollo 13 in 1970 at 2 45 p.m lunar
flyby officially begins the crew will have that time on their schedules to
begin photographing and providing audio recordings of what they are seeing on the Moon.
At 7.02 p.m., Orion will make its closest approach to the Moon, approximately 4,070
miles away.
Of course, all of these numbers are going to have to be confirmed following the flyby.
These are estimates, and we are working with orbital mechanics.
At 7.07 p.m. Orion reaches its maximum distance from Earth, approximately 252,760 miles away
from us all. At 8.35 p.m., the spacecraft will enter a solar eclipse. The crew will become the
first to see a solar eclipse from the moon. Ahead of the official beginning of flyby today,
Kelsey Young, Artemis Science Flight Operations Lead, will be conducting a pre-lunar flyby crew
conference. She will give information on camera setup, remind the crew of their intended targets,
answer questions from the astronauts, and more. Young will help the crew set their targeting
timeline which counts down the time they have to image each target and what they'll be capturing
next she'll also remind them what that the ground team will be calling for science sit reps also
known as situation reports those are essentially call downs to report what they've been observing
they'll continue to do this even through their los their loss of signal as those communications
will come down later on after they reconnect with us on earth this view in the cabin you can see the
the crew members are already using their cameras, getting set up, and they have dimmed the cabin
lights to allow them better visibility outside of the windows and fewer reflections. Now 28 minutes
until they become the humans to travel farthest from our planet. Is ready for the conference,
passing you over to science. Good morning crew, this is science. We couldn't be more excited for
a full day of lunar and planetary observations today, the first one in over 54 years. How do
hear me. Message received. I will keep it tight here. I did just want to start with a thank you
on behalf of the lunar science team and the entire lunar and planetary science community, of which
you are absolutely a part for what you've already done in this mission and what you're going to do
today to inspire the next generation of scientists. I have to say moon joy is the new term that's
already become our team's new motto, so thanks for that. In this conference, we'll cover hardware
and config reminders, and then I'll just briefly, as you said, cover today's science plan. I'm
Assuming you already have your LTPs up, confirm that,
and I'll jump quickly into the cabin config reminders.
The LTP up just to give you a sit rep on board.
You've got Reed and Christina on one PCD, and Ike has his own, and Jeremy has his own.
Copy that.
That was going to be one of my questions for you, and I'll ask a question back.
Is that the config that you and Christina plan to carry throughout the day for PCD use?
The green PCD will be in Window 3, and we will do that the whole day.
And then the red PCD will a rover.
Understood.
Super helpful.
Recommend when you guys switch in and out of PCDs to add your initials
to your OneNote annotations just so we can keep track of who's is who.
And then given that you have three PCDs instead of four for the data transfer at the end
of the day, recommend making a new subdirectory entitled
For science for your own photos or with your initials that we can keep track of which camera which pictures came from which flashcards
This view
Community cards in all cameras on board approaches their camp
They will put their card into that camera for photos and then put the community card back in at the end of the session
Understood. Thanks for that essay
Just read the flashcard numbers down when you get a chance
and we'll follow your lead on the best thing to do operationally during the
flyby with that I'll move on to windows so the window characterization DFT oh
you guys did a few days ago confirm that window 2 is ideal for imaging so no
change to config of photographer in window 2 observer in window 3 and
science that reps in window 1 coming up on the hand over as you heard science
officer called to the crew we are now in a handover time period we will regain
communications with the crew very shortly these are tracked and we are
currently on the deep space network this is the first time humans have used the
deep space network in over 50 years given that we currently use the tracking
data relay satellite systems in the for the International Space Station this
view from Artemis mission control on the right is Kelsey young that's who you
here speaking with the crew young is the Artemis science flight operations lead
and we also look forward to speaking with her here today again we are just
about 22 minutes until we reach the Apollo record we are in a handover of
satellites with the crew aboard Orion
for the Z-9 and solar, and then window three will be for visual observations,
and window four is for floater.
And thanks, and thanks, Integrity, for that read.
We had a handover during that time, so I'm going to have to ask you
to give that read back on window orientation for the crew again.
Window one has a t-shirt shroud, a long lens for window four is floater.
All right, copy all, Reid.
A note just on the window one t-shirt shoud that you can remove that
move that for the lunar observation block if you want to, if you want that extra view for
another floater, but defer to you guys on that. You are go to use the full 400 millimeter zoom
on the long lens, but where possible, try to keep the end of the lens flush with the window
to prevent imaging through the multiple window panes at an angle. And if you have to take an
image at an angle recommend you limit the max focal length to 200 millimeters or simply acquire
the images at multiple focal lengths last imaging update as a result of the dfto is that if you can
take the images out of the left side of window 2 where possible that is the best half the window
understand that might not be possible with the shroud any other imaging questions from you okay
last couple reminders don't forget the ability to take the wave files to tag imagery that you
are wanting to follow up on using the fn3 button on your camera and then a couple quick notes on
your ltp we have refined your precise flyby timing since generating the ltp optimus has the correct
timing for the LOS and AOS, but the LTP identifiers for LOS and
AOS are roughly two minutes later than they will be in reality.
Final LTP timing update is that the green line on your LTP should
start automatically 45 minutes before the flyby.
If it doesn't appear, let me know, and I'll have troubleshooting
steps for you.
Last updates are on the Eclipse, so only for that last hour today.
Of course, remember, if the sun is in view, to use your eclipse glasses.
And reminder that we will have a few activities for you prior to the eclipse to reconfigure all three cameras for corona and deep sky observations.
These activities, some of which will occur during the forward link LOS, so we wanted to flag it for you now.
Any questions before I cover the last two reminders?
last couple eclipse reminders the sunset period and the first roughly 23 minutes of the eclipse
will fall during that forward link los but we'll still have a return link and we're still looking
forward to your science sit reps and observations during that time and i do have reminder for you
on your preferred starting config for the eclipse in terms of role responsibility let me know if you
me to read that up or if you guys have that in your minds already and if no other questions on
config i'll give you a few science focused reminders okay um a couple changes from the
first ltp you studied are that is that glushko is the only feature that the same pair will view type
twice that's read and jeremy that's why that's the only target you see that is marked as one of one
and two one of two and two of two so om and oriental are in there twice but they're by
different pairs which is why you don't see them marked accordingly a note from feedback on your
observations so far over the last couple days a reminder that if you note structure and texture
as well as color and albedo please note any correlation between the two and also reminder
that negative observations are still valuable science so a lack of color or a lack of structure
associated with color is also valuable a reminder also that your observations so far indicate it
will likely take some time for your eyes to adjust we especially heard that around your terminator
observations and your color observations so reminder to know that your eye adaptation is
going to kind of come in throughout your shift and let us know when you start to see that nuance
Last reminder is around Earthset and Earthrise, when you're viewing us back here at home,
you'll be looking directly at Asia, Africa, and Oceania.
So I'm sure people watching from those places here on Earth will want to give you all a wave as you take their picture.
Any other questions from me, for me?
And right side, say, towards Window 1 or towards Window 3, and then we'll know that we are talking the same language.
Absolutely.
So I mean that the side of window two closest
to window three is preferred for imaging.
Again, we are in our pre-lunar flyby science conference
with Kelsey Young.
Kelsey Young is the Artemis science flight operations lead,
speaking with the crew aboard Orion.
They've been training for this moment for years
and this is their last opportunity
to get some further pointers and information.
For the T-shirt shroud, what window does the science team think will have the best view?
Is it window one or window four?
The only time we're strongly recommending use of the window shroud.
The window, the T- shirt window shroud for the eclipse.
Window one.
Window one is the most port window by the food warmer.
Window two is right in front of seat one.
We agree on the ground.
Good read back.
Kelsey, we're going to close the bases to hear all these terminologies being thrown around.
It's so great to hear your voice on the loops. I just want to channel everything that you guys are probably feeling right through my eyes and heart. It is awesome to see the side of the moon. You guys made us excited for this day, and we couldn't appreciate it anymore. And we are ready to hopefully deliver on all the awesome training you guys have provided.
And how does that Kelsey, it is blowing my mind what you can see
with the naked eye on the moon right now.
It's just to the whole lunar science team, all of you, all the work you put into this.
We're just grateful, can't wait to get going.
And thank you for the tip.
We can see them.
Beautiful words, you guys.
Thanks so much.
And I got video of the science team right now and they are all absolutely buzzing.
Looking forward to today.
Of the pre-lunar flyby science conference with Dr. Kelsey Young.
Young has served as the Artemis Science Flight Operations Lead, getting the crew ready.
And we're live in Artemis Mission Control in Houston,
but we are not the only room monitoring today's flyby.
As you heard Young mention, in this same building and just down the hall,
a multidisciplinary lunar science team supports the Artemis II crew in real time,
including experts in lunar geology, impact cratering,
volcanism, polar science, imaging, and visualization.
There are two integrated facilities, and the first is the SUR,
which is what you have right here.
That's the science evaluation room.
They are embedded within Mission Control
to provide science input during live operations
like what we see today.
Additionally, and not pictured,
we have the science mission operations room,
a back room that processes data, evaluates imagery,
and supports rapid analysis.
Our science officer on console in Mission Control Houston
serves as the primary interface between the science team
and the flight controllers,
ensuring science priorities are represented during mission
execution. Again today that's Dr. Kelsey Young who will be speaking with the crew
during the time they're behind the moon. We will be speaking
with her once the crew is behind the moon and out of communication with Earth.
Back inside the Orion spacecraft on your left, closest to the camera, NASA
astronaut Christina Koch. To her left, NASA astronaut Reid Wiseman. To his left,
Canadian Space Agency astronaut Jeremy Hansen. And all the way in the back, NASA
astronaut Victor Glover, our Artemis 2 crew. We are now approaching eight
minutes until the crew surpasses the Apollo 13 record. Currently 12,599
miles away from the Moon, 248,507 miles away from Earth. We, you know, you
may also hear the Orion spacecraft referred to today as Integrity. This was
named by the Artemis two crew it is integrity crew we have Reid's family in
the viewing gallery you're welcome to say hello I'm seeing a lot of hearts
come out of the viewing gallery and even more smiles thanks Reid copy heart copy
bracelet that call from Capcom Jenny Gibbons Canadian Space Agency astronaut
and Artemis to backup crew member letting Reid Wiseman know that he has
family here to support him today in the artemis mission control viewing room as i was mentioning
we have the orion spacecraft flying today however the Artemis crew members named their orion
spacecraft integrity so you will hear calls to this entire crew with the name integrity they say
that the name integrity embodies the foundation of trust respect candor and humility across the
crew and the many engineers technicians scientists planners and dreamers required for mission success
this view live from the outside of Orion as we continue preparing for our lunar flyby now less
than five minutes from surpassing the record set by Apollo 13 astronauts for the farthest humans
to travel from Earth this will not be the farthest that integrity travels today they
will continue until they reach approximately a distance of 250 2760 miles that would be about
4,105 miles farther than Apollo 13. However, these numbers are our targets and we will get
confirmation on those numbers as soon as we possibly can and share them with you all.
We've talked a little bit about what to expect from the crew, whether that's taking photos or
making audio recordings. To get a little more detailed, Reid Wiseman and Jeremy Hansen will
be up first to capture imagery and record audio on the portable computing devices.
you hear those referred to as PCDs, while Victor and Christina serve as the support members.
The crew will switch windows and rolls halfway through their shift and one hour and five minutes
later Victor Glover and Christina Koch will be the next crew members at windows two and three
to take photos and make annotations while Reed and Jeremy take on those support roles. There are five
viewing blocks and the crew will swap out with each one. During two of the blocks the two support
members will also be able to enjoy their midday meal at least three times per block is a science
set rep again situational report this is partially an operational status reporting back if they
missed any targets or gotten any specific ones if they have issues with their camera or any other
operational items the other part is an actual description of the moon this task is done by one
of the support team astronauts so that's not the crew currently taking photos or making annotations
but they do have windows one and four that they can float up and provide that information from
if you watch the entirety of the flyby you'll also notice the crew will be photographing
some targets multiple times to get observations in different lighting conditions
this is due to orion changing their location throughout the flyby what this crew will be
able to capture in a couple of hours of the same targets in different lighting
would take orbiters years to do because of solar and spacecraft positioning
This crew has studied the moon extensively, and they're also familiar with what the science team calls the Big 15.
These are 15 features that they've memorized, so at any time, they'll be able to see five of those
and help orient themselves in where they are around the moon.
Those targets are diverse and complex in their geologic history,
and observations of them could help answer some big-picture science questions.
If you've been following the mission, you can see that the configuration of the cabin
is a little bit different than what it looked like on launch day.
After ascent, the crew were allowed to reconfigure their spacecraft.
You can see that they've taken down seats.
They have also taken away footrests.
This gives them more opportunity to move about the spacecraft.
Orion itself has 330 cubic feet of habitable volume.
That's about the size of two minivans and is 60% more cubic volume than the Apollo spacecraft.
We are standing by for the Integrity crew aboard Orion to surpass the Apollo 13 record.
Integrity crew, on April 15, 1970, during the Apollo 13 mission, three explorers set
the record for the farthest distance humans have ever traveled from our home planet.
At that time, over 55 years ago, Lovell, Swigert, and Hayes flew 248,655 statute miles away
from earth today for all humanity you're pushing beyond that frontier integrity over to you we will
continue our journey even further into space before mother earth succeeds in pulling us back
to everything that we hold here thank you integrity and congratulations to you and the rest
of the artemis ii team the first one so if you were to look at oriental on the far side and then
and then draw a line straight up to Om on the far side.
Relatively in the middle is an unnamed crater,
and we would like to suggest it be called Integrity
in the future.
And the second one, and especially meaningful
for this crew, is a number of years ago,
we started this journey in our close-knit,
and we lost a love, just on the near side of that boundary.
We will be able to, we lost a loved one, the mother.
If you want to find this one, you look at Glushko,
just to the northwest of that.
Integrity and Carol Crater. Loud and clear. Thank you.
As the Artemis II crew passed the record set by Apollo 13 for the farthest humans to ever fly from Earth at 12.57 p.m. Central Time, 1.57 p m. Eastern Time,
Canadian Space Agency astronaut Jeremy Hansen shared.
Sounds good. We're doing the same down here and you are maneuvering to your observation attitude.
As we passed that Apollo 13 record of the furthest humans to ever fly from Earth at 1257 p.m. Central Time, 157 p.m., Eastern Time,
the Artemis II crew shared some poignant words, specifically Canadian Space Agency astronaut Jeremy Hansen.
The crew also called down two craters not yet named that they would like to name.
One, Integrity, in honor of their spacecraft, which they have named.
That's near the Ohm Crater.
Another near Glushko, which is a bright spot, named Carol, in memory of Reid Wiseman's wife.
There was a moment of silence here in Mission Control Houston, and now the team and the Artemis II crew are ready to begin their lunar flyby.
We are four days, 19 hours, 31 minutes mission elapsed time of the flight of Artemis II, our four astronauts aboard Orion.
Today is our lunar flyby day.
The spacecraft is currently about 12,000 miles away from the Moon and you can keep
up with the distance from Orion to the Moon and Earth by visiting nasa.gov slash trackartemis.
Or you can just stay with us here because we're going to be telling you throughout the day.
They are currently 248,834 miles away from planet Earth.
Coming up next on the cruise timeline today will be their cabin configuration portion.
You heard some calls down to science officer Dr. Kelsey Young earlier
about how they have configured the cabin so far.
This is just a little bit more of a timeline activity for them if they need to further do so.
On flight day three, the crew had time on their schedule allotted
for configuring the spacecraft cabin for how they intended to arrange it today.
Of course, they had to take down that configuration for another test yesterday
of their Orion Crew Survival System suits, but configuring it
on flight day three allows them the opportunity to get a chance to see what works for them now
what works for them now that they are in the microgravity environment. Again, the crew is about to begin their cabin
configuration portion of their timeline though they have been working that already as well as
potentially during their post sleep period this morning the official lunar flyby observations
are slated to begin in just about 40 minutes that's when we'll have the crew at the windows
photographing the moon as well as making calls down about what they are seeing.
Again we are live here in Artemis Mission Control for the duration of the flyby.
Currently the Orbit 1 flight control team is on console. This room is staffed 24-7 from the time
before the astronauts step foot on the rocket until the time they are splashed down and are
safely recovered in the Pacific Ocean on flight day 10. Again this is Artemis Mission
Control here in Houston. We are now 11,777 miles away from the Moon. We did pass the Apollo 13
record of farthest humans away from Earth at 1257 p.m. Central Time, 157 p.m Eastern Time.
That distance 248,655 statute miles from the Earth continuing to be exceeded by the crew.
They will reach their farthest distance from the Earth around 6.07 p.m. Central Time.
At that time, they will be in an LOS or a loss of signal with us on Earth as they'll be flying behind the Moon.
As the crew gets into their cabin configuration preparations, we are joined by Dr. Sarah Noble, the Artemis Lunar Science Lead.
Thanks for joining us here today.
Yeah, it's quite a day.
Yeah, we are very excited. I can only imagine how you guys are doing over there.
So tell me a little bit about yourself and what your role is for Artemis II.
Artemis too? Sure. So I'm the Artemis Lunar Science Lead, so over the entire campaign. And
my job is basically to make sure that as we have this big adventure back to the Moon,
we actually learn new things about the Moon. Fascinating. So why is the Moon such an
important destination today? Yeah, so the Moon is a pretty amazing place. It is a great place
to learn about basic fundamental processes that happen on like all the planets, like cratering
and volcanology. And also, it is, you know, part of our Earth-Moon system. And, you know
the Earth recycles its rocks pretty well, right, through plate tectonics and weathering
and whatever. Most of the rocks on the Earth are geologically young. But on the Moon, we
have the entire record that goes back 4.5 billion years since we formed. And so, if
we really want to learn about what was happening in that period, like, the Moon is really the
only place we can go.
We're also thinking about going back to the Moon, and we want to go to the
lunar south pole so what makes that such an interesting destination yeah the south pole is
cool right it's it's far away from the places we went during apollo it's different kinds of rocks
there's some of the oldest rocks on the on the moon it's also a place where we think there might
be resources like water there are craters that that really never can see the sun because of the
low sun angles there and they get very cold and and and we think that water and other things can
build up in those craters since we're very interested to see what that might do for us
I'm very interested as well. So for some of our viewers who might be new to this,
what does lunar science look like during an Artemis mission?
Yeah, it's pretty exciting for us as we have sort of built this from scratch to try to understand
how we can best use the crew to support our science. And so, you know, we've developed a
system. We've got a team in place. We've a back room here, here in this building called the SUR,
the Science Evaluation Room. And there's a back room to that back room over in another,
another building here at Johnson Space Center where we've got our teams of scientists working
really hard. They're actually speaking to this room through our science officer. This is now
the first time we've ever had a science officer in flight control room. So we're pretty excited
about that. So we have a really voice out and up to the crew. I know it's been so exciting to hear
Dr. Kelsey Young speaking directly with the crew today now so close to the moon. And we have a live
view here of the science operation or the science evaluation room. So this is where the majority of
your team is today. Is that right? Yeah, that's right. This is a big chunk of our scientists.
You can see them in there now working hard, trying to get ready for the day.
And then, again, there's a second room where we have a lot of our data folks
where the data will first come down, and they'll sort of sift through the data
and get ready for this team to take.
What's the mood like right now in the CER?
It is, I would say, giddy.
I think we've worked very hard for this.
They have done simulation after simulation.
They have worked really hard over the last couple of years to get ready
for this moment, and I think everybody's just really excited to see,
You know, even already we've had some descriptions from the crew coming down, and it's so great to see their joy and our joy, our love for the moon, come through.
Yes, we are in for a real treat today, if it's been anything like their observations the past couple of days.
So how are the lunar science teams using this test flight to prepare for future missions to the moon?
Yeah, absolutely.
This is the way that we are building our foundation for the future, from everything from, you know, how do you train a crew to be a geologist, right?
And so, you know, working through that, getting them classroom training, field training,
building the science team, building these physical rooms that we are in, designing them,
designing the software that the teams are using.
And then, you know figuring out what happens to that data.
They're going to take this data and it's going to come down and how do we get it
out to not only our team but out to the world and the rest of the science community.
Yeah, that's a great point because when you hear these crew members talk,
you would never know that they're not geologists.
Your team has trained them so well.
They have been very good students.
Who can blame them?
it's a pretty great topic. One more question for you. How does the science that we're doing on
Artemis help support long-term exploration and including our sustained presence on the moon?
Yeah, you know what? We have a saying in the Science Mission Directorate that science enables
exploration and exploration enables science, right? So you need the scientists because we
are the ones who are the experts in, you know, landing site and doing analysis of landing site
and making sure we can find a good place to land to like understanding the properties of the soil
so we can you know design our systems to manage that understanding the radiation environment
keeping our astronauts safe all these things right but you know in return you provide us
with opportunities where now we're going to be able to collect this data and collect samples
and deploy our instruments and all that so it's a symbiotic relationship that makes perfect sense
well dr sarah noble artemis lunar science lead thank you so much for joining us here today best
of luck to your you and your team and i hope that you get to enjoy today too thank you so
much we are now getting closer and closer to our lunar neighbor this live
view coming from the Orion spacecraft and a camera mounted on one of its solar
array wings ready to copy for the various positions for the long lens on
the d5 we will have individual card we'll have one dedicated card for today
Serial number 1022.
All right, Christina, we copy all.
Most full in the Earth.
Amaze, amaze, amazze.
Thank you, Reid.
Those are some of the communications we're excited most about today.
Commander Reid Wiseman calling down their view right now,
obviously a little bit different than what we can see from the solar array camera.
They are looking through the windows of the Orion spacecraft,
able to see at the same time Earth and the moon.
You also heard NASA astronaut Christina Koch calling down some
of the cameras that they will be using today.
The crew is in that cabin configuration portion
and we expect the lunar flyby observation period
to start in just about 20 minutes.
Checking in on Orion's distance and speed,
they are currently traveling 1,071 miles per hour,
hour, 249,159 miles away from Earth, 11,293 miles away from the Moon, and continuing to grow closer.
At closest approach to the Moon today, the spacecraft will be just about 4,070 miles away from
the lunar surface. This will be during our loss of signal with the crew as they travel behind the
Moon, and we will await their return to get the official number for you for how close they come
to our lunar neighbor.
Inside the cabin today, the Lunar Targeting Package is the primary tool guiding the crew
observations and consists of two key components.
The Lunar Geography Review helped the astronauts study major lunar features in advance and
help learn how to orient themselves during the flyby.
Because, of course, the moon is not actually labeled like it appears here when we look
at this map.
The Lunar Target Plan provides a detailed timeline of observation targets, background
science context and specific instructions for the pictures the crew should take, as
well as the verbal descriptions that will be helpful to the science team reviewing them
later.
This is a screenshot from their lunar targeting package, and a screenshot specifically of
that lunar...
Go ahead.
The vehicle down to get the D5 long lens flush and have the least amount of window distortion.
We're checking.
That call from Christina Koch, NASA Astronaut and Mission Specialist on Artemis II.
The Orion spacecraft is positioned in a specific attitude to allow the crew to best see the
moon outside of their windows today for this imaging opportunity.
That call was a request for a potential attitude shift just slightly, another five degrees,
to give them a better view and to give them better opportunity to use their long lens
camera.
They'll also be using that lunar targeting package we were discussing.
I am following along with that real time, so I'll be able to share with you exactly
what targets the crew is looking at and when.
They also trained with a lunar science passport, it's a little reference guide used on Earth
to reinforce recognition of key lunar features.
It is not on the flight, but it was a significant study tool for the crew to get them ready
for launch.
The apparent size of the moon will change throughout the flyby, and it'll appear roughly
like a basketball held at arm's length at the crew's closest approach.
That reinforces the need for careful planning and practiced observation techniques.
Houston, integrity for timeline.
Go ahead.
Absolutely sure that we are showing EP, Discussion 1.
Firm, you'd like us to start Discussion 1 in 29 minutes at 1900 GMT?
Christina, we are tracking that Discussion 1 should start at 1845, that's 15 minutes
from now.
Okay, copy all.
It may be a granularity issue with LTP, but understand that we start in LTP will match.
Copy and we'll look into that a little bit more on our side as well.
Christina, can you verify for us that your green line is moving on the timeline page
of your LTP?
I see the labels are just not aligned with the start or end times of the white visible bands.
It fully makes sense now, so I think we are all set. We'll look forward to it.
Copy. Thanks, Christina.
As you heard discussed, we are expecting the crew's observation time period to start in about 10 minutes.
First, they'll be conducting a warm-up, warming up to their science observations of the moon.
They'll be discussing with each other, helping each other orient using the major landmarks
that they've studied, asking what is familiar.
If we roll left, port five degrees.
Copy, Victor.
We'd like to know if it's pitch and roll or one or the other.
The pitch in.
Has the pitch been put?
No, we need a little while longer to talk about it.
Continue to move in the window or is the spacecraft going to keep the moon at the same point of the window?
Right now we are pointing the center of the window to the center of
the moon with two degrees of dead band.
The conversation you hear happening now between the astronauts aboard Orion
and Artemis Mission Control here at Johnson Space Center in Houston, Texas.
They are in the center of your screen seated at the CAPCOM or Capsule Communicator console.
That's Jenny Gibbons, Canadian Space Agency astronaut, and Artemis II backup.
She was also the lead CAPCOM for Expedition 63 aboard the International Space Station.
The crew is requesting some attitude changes to the spacecraft to allow them to better image the moon, our priority for today.
Of course, those have to be discussed on the ground before they are put into work aboard the spacecraft, so the team is taking some time to do so.
You also heard Gibbons reference that we are in two dead bands.
Dead bands are essentially keeping us in the lane in which we're traveling.
If you're familiar with lane assist in your car, very similar in this case.
We are now 10,870 miles away from the moon,
traveling 1,066 miles per hour and 249,390 miles away from Earth.
Again, we recently surpassed the Apollo 13 distance record of farthest humans have ever
traveled.
And upon calling down some words during that milestone, Canadian Space Agency astronaut
Jeremy Hansen noting that he hopes that this record that they are setting today is soon
broken by future explorers.
This is Artemis Mission Control.
We are standing by for the beginning of lunar flyby, expecting that to start in just a few
minutes when the crew will begin a warm-up discussion preparing for the day
they will be capturing images along while discussing what they find familiar
about the moon and what looks unexpected to them again just minutes away from the
official start of lunar flyby or when it is timelined for the crew we are
currently 10,726 miles away from the moon this view on the left side of your
screen coming from the camera on one of Orion's solar arrays.
Other conversation points while the crew are getting ready for their flyby today.
They'll be looking to orient themselves using major landmarks and annotating their observations
along with their discussion.
They'll have 10 minutes for that warm-up discussion.
We have two folks at the window deep in discussion talking about all of the awesome features
that they're seeing.
We just had a huge moment realizing that Hertzsprung is about the same size as our incredible Oriental.
We're really excited about this target that's kind of new to us.
We're orienting on things like how we talk about albedo, finding some of the prevalent
things that we're used to from all of our training overall taking in this view we also are noticing
that it is the moon is still getting noticeably bigger as we go even when you're watching it
continuously it's great to see these two guys get warmed up we love the report christina thanks and
you nailed it on why we added hertz as you'll see in the prompts we're looking for comparisons to
the comparatively much older hertz sprung compared to the younger oriental great words this is artemis
Mission Control, that was the voice of Dr. Kelsey Young speaking with the astronauts aboard Orion
as they begin their observation period and lunar flyby.
NASA astronaut Christina Koch reporting their view of Hertzsprung Basin.
The team here is looking for centered images of the basin at a full zoom and they're hoping
that the astronauts can image and describe the inner and outer rings.
This is considered a degraded basin with a floor, rings and ejecta compared
to a younger oriental basin we talked we spoke earlier with julia julian gross the artemis
curation lead about some of the terms we will hear the crew use today one of those just called out
that's albedo looking at surface brightness or the amount of light a surface reflects
a few more terms that we hope to hear today during the cruise sit reps or situation reports
include embaying this refers to one feature that surrounds another that usually is a higher relief
feature houston integrity one report from the crew at the windows we can actually see the moon and
earth at the same time right now interesting because the earth looks way brighter so the
earth itself seems to have a much higher albedo than the moon we think this is independent of
our eyes focusing because of course the earth is much smaller than the moon in our view so you
could think that your eyes focus for the darker sky and that it means that it only has a parent
same view we do think that this can be inferred as the earth as a whole has a higher albedo
great observation christina and reminder that as you're starting to look for those subtle color
and albedo variations on the moon the relatively bright albedo earth might make those a little bit
difficult but as your eyes continue to adjust we expect you to start to see more nuance on the moon
thanks we're all going to be experts in lunar terminology by the end of the day another one
we expect to hear is mare these are dark regions paved or filled by volcanic deposits you also can
You can hear them called seas, oceans, lakes, or marshes, or other bodies of water.
Again, we are live in Artemis Mission Control, but on the right side of your screen, that
is the Science Evaluation Room, team members who have been preparing for this day for years.
The crew has significantly darkened the cabin of Orion.
This allows them better views outside the windows and fewer reflections from inside.
They reported being able to see the Moon and the Earth out the same window at this time.
We are really hopeful to get those photos.
Right now, this view on the left side of your screen coming from a camera mounted on one
of the solar array wings on Orion outside the spacecraft.
The crew is equipped with 80 to 400 millimeter zoom lenses.
The team continues their warm-up discussion.
I should say the crew members aboard Orion continue their warm- up discussion, however,
They are about to be prompted to move on to discussion number two, which is nearside and
farside.
Some of the things that they are looking to capture, the ground has prompted them to photograph
anything that stands out to them and to compare the nearside versus the farside mare in color,
albedo, topography, and texture.
They also want the crew to compare the appearance of raid craters in the nearsides mare versus
in the farsides highlands.
Of course, a reminder that some of the items that the crew or some of the landmarks the crew are seeing today is the first time
that humans have ever laid eyes on those portions of the moon.
In the targeting package, there are a few reminders of the crew.
For the crew, there are time-sensitive observation reminders and science SITREP reminders.
Integrity. We have a SITREP. The targets that are being discussed right now, it's
the far side, near side, the browns and green toward the North Pole. You lose the
color, you've got window one, under window, I'm sorry. Integrity Science, Victor, very
glad that you provided the first formal science SITREPs as these were indeed
your idea. One follow-up question, any relationship between those browns and
greens you described. Do you see them blending into one another and do you see any topography
associated with either color? I don't want to bother the window team. I will e-drop and see
if I can pick that up. I will try to answer that at some point fully or maybe higher. I'll get some
more information to correlate those colors from Aristarchus for you. Understood, Victor, and good
call to not bug the window team, really like the brightness comparisons to Burgess A, really
helpful for the science team. Keep them coming. Thanks.
From all deepening the job to the...
Copy all, Victor. And you read our mind. Superlatives like darkest, biggest are really,
really helpful for us. So keep those coming.
As we were just mentioning, the crew is slated to perform these science sit reps.
They are prompted to do so by an icon in their lunar targeting plan.
That one coming down from NASA astronaut and pilot of Artemis II, Victor Glover.
As we discussed, the CAPCOM is usually the only person
in the room speaking with the crew, the capsule communicator.
However, today the science officer, Dr. Kelsey Young,
she is the Artemis science flight operations lead,
is speaking with the group during the flyby
to ask any questions that the team may have.
To her right is Trevor Graff.
He is one of three science officers.
Those would be Kelsey Young, Trevor Graff,
and Angela Garcia who will also join us later for an interview.
Houston Integrity out of window one, which is a beautiful view.
I can see the entire moon that they're looking at.
We left it once I was able to get two eyes on it.
What jumped out at me was Vavilov.
It's just peeking out of the terminus out because it's still got the low light,
the low sun angle and so where the, you know, Vavilov has that sect on the eastern edge
So, on the crew oriental.
Love the description, Victor, especially the comparison
and relationships you just described about topography.
And if it's easier for your observations, do feel free
to remove the t-shirt shroud from window one.
Those calls coming from NASA astronaut Victor Glover.
As we discussed, the crew is working in pairs at the windows.
Right now, taking photos are Commander Reid Wiseman
And Mission Specialist Jeremy Hansen, serving as their support team,
our pilot Victor Glover and Mission Specialist Christina Koch.
You're hearing those calls from Victor Glover as he is on that support team,
and he is tasked with providing the science SITREPS.
While the two crew photographing and making annotations of the moon are in Windows 2 and 3,
Windows 1 and 4 are available for the support crew to fly up to,
obviously look at the moon themselves and provide these science situational
reports. The view on your screen is part of the lunar targeting package and it's
something that the crew can reference as they are flying by but this is an
animation. You also heard Glover mention Oriental. Oriental is a major feature
that the team is interested in today and it's known as the Grand Canyon of the
moon until this mission grant oriental basin had never been seen in sunlight by human eyes oriental
basin and its surrounding ejecta could fit within a straight line distance from nasa's johnson space
center where we are at today to a kennedy space center this alive view in artemis mission control
in houston texas where the teams are monitoring all systems not just for today's flyby but on the
spacecraft themselves. Again, this is a test flight, our very first flight of humans on the
Orion spacecraft. This team has been live, this team has been monitoring the entire time of the
mission as well as we have been live the entirety of the mission and we will be continuing to do so
all the way through splashdown and crew recovery from the Pacific. This is a visualization from
Arrow, the Artemis real-time orbit website that you can also access at any time
by visiting nasa.gov slash track Artemis, showing us that we are now under 10,000 miles
from the moon, 9,948 to be specific, and continuing to count down.
Again, our closest approach to the moon today should come about 6.02 p.m. central, 7.02 p
m. eastern.
However, we will be out of contact with the crew at this time as they begin transiting
behind the moon.
At that time of closest approach, the distance from Orion to the lunar surface will be about 4,070 miles.
Of course, these are estimates at this time, and we'll be sure to provide you with the official numbers once that closest approach has been reached.
This shot live inside the Orion spacecraft, where our four crew members are continuing with their lunar flyby activities.
They have just begun those activities really about 20 minutes ago so we've got
several hours of moon view opportunities. This is still a live view inside that
capsule however you can see just how dark they have turned down the lights.
Actually they've turned them all the way off. There are a few LEDs that they
cannot power off but turning down these lights gives them better views outside
of the spacecraft's windows while they photograph the moon. This also prevents
any reflections from inside the spacecraft bouncing up on the windows
and interfering with their photography as we were previously discussing the
crew members are serving on teams the first team being commander Reid Wiseman
and mission specialist Jeremy Hansen at the windows photographing what they see
we heard reports earlier that they could see both the moon and the earth in the
same view and we are looking forward to seeing the moon and
earth in the same view as well that earth set coming up in just a few hours
While Wiseman and Hansen are at the windows photographing, Glover and Cook
are serving as support crew. They are able to assist with cameras. They are
also providing those situation reports letting us know how the team is working
inside the spacecraft, what they're seeing and how they're feeling about it.
Those first blocks of teams will last about an hour and the crew members are
approaching the halfway point into their first observation block. A reminder we
have five of those blocks today. So they're approaching this halfway point during which the
crew at the window will switch roles. One will begin taking pictures and the other will be making
annotations on their PCD, that's portable computing device. Both of those crew members at the windows
are recording audio of what they see. They are putting on headsets and recording audio into their
portable computing devices. Obviously we are not hearing this right now. This is going to be sent
down to the science team and they will be able to analyze that at a later time.
What we are hearing though, and we'll continue to hear,
are those science sit reps a few times every block.
Once this block is complete, about 40 minutes from now, we will have the teams switch.
That means pilot Victor Glover and...
Science integrity, looking out of window one, I think I may have misreported earlier saying
that it was Tycho going over the horizon.
It was Copernicus is what is farthest bounding to the east and that is now like on the horizon
or just past it and the is now a few degrees from going over the horizon
and then, you know, next it will be similar to the feature, I cannot remember, just alpha.
Love the descriptions.
You're definitely looking odd up there.
appreciate seeing the training being implemented especially interested in your descriptions of the
dark patches you compared the comma looking features to the albedo you see in grimaldi
and notice that you're starting to see those color differences popping out any observations
you want to make especially when you get on you know the pcd in a little bit would really help
us tease out the differences in those dark mare deposits great description victor keep them coming
Absolutely will do, and I know you've got descriptions on both of the window observers.
Great evidence of how well trained this crew is by the science team.
NASA astronaut and pilot of the Artemis II mission, Victor Glover,
calling down a situation report noting several different features on the moon
and such descriptions even saying that it looks like snow on some of the peaks.
Obviously we do not expect that to be snow, but referencing that as some
some of the lighting on how it looks to the Artemis 2 crew from their current position.
The team is slated to be switching their positions at the windows now.
Both Reid Wiseman and Jeremy Hansen have been at windows 2 and 3, one taking photos, one
making observations and annotations on their portable computing device.
At this time, we also anticipate that they are looking at a crater duo.
One of those is Glushko, and the other is Ohm.
The team is looking to know the extent of Glushko's ray system and how its rays differ
in the Mare versus the highlands.
They also want the team to compare the ray systems of Glushiko to Ohm.
Ohm is considered a young crater.
If you've ever seen a photo of the Richat structure, it's also known as the Eye of the
Sahara.
It's 40 kilometers in diameter and that could fit within Ohm's interior.
The team is specifically interested in descriptions of that ray visibility, including the color
albedo.
Remember, albedo is the brightness or the surface reflection and the reach.
Again, I am using the same lunar targeting package that the crew is referencing on board
right now.
keep them on time, as well as prompt them for when they need to make a call down to the science team and report what they're saying.
It also gives them reminders of when they need swap positions at the windows.
Additionally, I'm using the Artemis II Lunar Science Passport, developed by Amber Turner and the Artemis 2 Lunar Science Team.
Now, this passport did not fly with the crew, but they used it extensively as a study guide here on Earth.
So a lot of the descriptions and comparisons you hear today are developed directly by the
science team.
We are now four days, 20 hours, and 43 minutes.
Science, integrity, that crater to the north, that is like a, we've got one in the north
that looks like one on the south side, about that is left or just a high albedo.
If a majority of the craters between the two craters, it's hard to tell from this grid
show you where that albedo surrounds.
science thanks for that we agree with the Pythagoras assessment and as a
follow-up to your previous report the sir had questions about topography
comparisons between the North Pole and the South Pole of the moon if you're
willing to provide words on that if you have any idea what if you draw a line
the outer I would love to know the name of that the topography differences now
the South Pole has a little bit of a benefit that it has more of the
Terminator and I can see a little more shadowing there but I can see some very
jagged shadows at 90 degree just to the west of that I could see a wall or to be
that pitch of the mare that's dark which is maybe one Pythagoras diameter if you
draw a ring about that you know maybe the top seven degrees of the moon and
just draw a ring around that the near side is an albedo of five and then along
the same edge of the mare the edge of the mari that kind of Grimaldi's just
outside of, Glushko is just outside of, Carroll Crater is just outside
of, and you start to see the stark differences between the darker seven
eights and the fives and sixes, the fours and fives. If you follow that line up to
the north, that line is also where the change in topography happens at the
North Pole. The line defining the light and dark on the edge of the mare that
you can see from Earth. Draw that line, roughly the midpoint of all that,
straight to the North Pole and on the side with their topography and see a lot more cratering
and a lot more topography of a little termite, a more challenging place.
Copy all, Victor.
You really helped paint a contextual picture of what you're looking at.
We really appreciate the way that you're guiding us into the areas you're seeing by drawing
comparisons between recognizable features.
Thanks for that.
Kelsey, another little science from the window team is the more I look at the moon,
no hardware issues. They did start to talk a little bit about another feature that you'll
hear more about on the that was at the end of their glushko and before they moved into their
current target they thought that was worth chatting a little bit more about. Houston copies and concurs.
Another just observation from the human uh here I've been wearing my reading glasses to look at
the PCD of the window inside of the dark cabin and trying to work cam back into the cabin. Appreciate
that report victor and know that we are prepared to read you up targets from the ground if that
would give you the ability to keep your eyes focused on the moon and not having to swap
between that and the pcd just let us know we'll we'll back each other up that way as well but we
appreciate that we may take you up on that thanks continued detailed descriptions from the artemis
ii crew aboard orion again this is a test flight the first time we've flown humans aboard this
spacecraft. So every detail, even that it's difficult to look outside the window and then
back at the PCD, that portable computing device, every single detail is appreciated as we prepare
for future missions. Glover also mentioned that he is now wearing his glasses now that he's in space
and that his eyes have shifted a bit. This is something that happens when our astronauts go
to space. There is a fluid shift from the lower half of your body up into your head and that can
cause changes in your eyes it's something that we have seen over time for some crew members
especially now that we have been living and working on the international space station for
over 25 years again it's clear that these artemis ii astronauts have undergone extensive lunar
science training including classroom instruction field work and high fidelity simulations training
expeditions even took place in analog environments like the icelandic highlands and the chem assassin
impact crater in Labrador, where crews practiced identifying and describing geologic features
under varying conditions.
Additionally here at Johnson Space Center, Orion mockups were used to rehearse crew choreography,
including three-dimensional space management with an inflatable moon globe to simulate
the flyby.
And while on Earth, the crew also used that small lunar passport that I mentioned with
descriptions, photos and prompts to help them study the features we hope they'll see.
Now this is a view from their lunar targeting package at this time, helping them determine
what they're seeing on the moon, as well as on the left, keep up with what their next
target will be.
As you can see, we have got a long list and an exciting day ahead of us.
It's now been four days, 20 hours and 53 minutes since Orion launched atop the Space Launch
System rocket from Kennedy Space Center in Florida with our four crew members aboard.
NASA astronauts Reid Wiseman, Victor Glover, and Christina Koch, and Canadian Space Agency
astronaut Jeremy Hansen.
The Artemis II crew passed a major milestone today when they passed the Apollo 13 distance
record at 1257 p.m. Central, 157 p.m., Eastern.
That Apollo 13 distance record was 248,655 statute miles from Earth.
Houston, another observation, whole moon.
When you look at the moon, something I've never seen in photos, new craters are pretty small.
There's a couple that really stand out, obviously.
We copy, Christina. Thank you.
Looks like you guys might be doing it, but remind you to swap positions at the window and take your SD cards with you.
We're loving everything that you're calling down, so keep it up.
Again, Orion previously surpassed the Apollo 13 greatest distance from Earth by humans.
That was 248,655 statute miles from Earth, and Orion now 250,294 miles away from our home planet.
The spacecraft is 9,033 miles away from the moon and growing ever closer.
At its closest approach, it will be about 4,070 miles away, and we will make sure we confirm what that distance ends up being.
This is an approximation and an estimate ahead of that moment.
We're anticipating them to make that closest approach at 6.02 p.m. Central, 7.02 pm. Eastern.
When they are in a loss of signal transiting behind the moon, they will be the first humans in over 50 years to fly behind the moon and lose contact with Earth.
We will regain that contact about 40 minutes later as they reconnect to the deep space network
emerging from behind the moon, and we will look forward to seeing an Earth rise.
Again, the crew is currently in their position swap portion on their timeline.
This allows crew members the opportunity and the experience of all roles necessary during today's flyby.
Right now, those two crew members at the window have swap positions.
Again, the crew at the windows swapping positions.
Right now that crew is Commander Reid Wiseman and Mission Specialist Jeremy Hansen, while
Victor Glover and Christina Koch serve as their support flyby crew members.
That's why you are hearing Victor and Christina during those science situation reports.
Those voices will change in about 30 minutes when they take a turn taking photos and making
annotations while at the window.
I wanted to provide an observation for a little bit of something that we saw completely different than the normal view we have of the nearside.
It is the limb view that we had.
And it's the mountain chains that form its eastern, as I'm used to seeing, even on the western side.
And the whole thing just feels like a big bump.
It actually looks like a large healing wound with a high albedo forming the mountain chain around a couple days ago.
Christina, science, absolutely love that, especially since that's a feature that all of us here on Earth can observe from home.
So I'm sure tonight everyone's going to be going out and looking for evidence of that beautiful topography you just said.
Thanks for those words.
The view on your screen coming from Orion, a camera mounted on the spacecraft's solar array wing.
Toward the right of your screen, the near side is the hemisphere we see from Earth.
That is identifiable by those dark splotches, which are ancient lava flows.
Sorry, science, integrity.
Question, is it possible that we're seeing a Schrodinger basin?
Integrity, science, that is very intriguing, those color rays coming out of OM rather than sort of albedo.
So, and as answer to your question, we do not think you can see Schrodinger.
It's in darkness as of now.
But thanks for that OM description.
And it sounds like the pair at the window has got great descriptions that we're definitely going to dive into tonight.
Okay.
If you could help me, I would still love to know what it is they're saying.
What would be right in the Terminator at the South Pole or close?
Yeah, Victor, we're assuming you're talking about, you know, kind of if you're looking at the Terminator,
where it's basically like 70% down from the North Pole.
Is that where you're looking?
Integrity, Houston, that is an enabled caution for wastewater dump required.
We have hit our limit. As expected, no crew action.
UR.
And Integrity Science, we're trying to figure out what you're looking at there.
Is it like right on the Terminator, or is it in the eliminated portion next to the Terminator?
While we wait for a response from the crew, the Terminator is that difference between day and night or brightness and darkness that you see on the moon.
We see this from the International Space Station as well looking down at Earth.
If you draw a line between Glushko and from Glushko, mine would almost perfectly intersect.
That line description was really helpful.
really helpful I have eyes on the sir right now and they are actively
discussing lunar geography we will be back with you shortly you're hearing a
couple of voices today in Mission Control Houston one of those is dr.
Kelsey young integrity science we believe that's Zeman crater we believe
that that is Zeman crater I may be pronouncing that wrong what's the first
letter of that work? Zulu. It's Z-E-E-M-A-N. Looking more into Babelov. I've got a nice great
view into Babelof. I'm going to go try to give you some bounding orders on the view that we're
seeing, but I've got to get back to a window in a minute. Understood, Victor. You're defining new
views of the moon in more ways than one. Again, when you hear calls down to science or from
science, that's Dr. Kelsey Young, the Artemis Science Flight Operations Lead here at a console
in mission control. You also hear communications with the crew from Canadian Space Agency astronaut
Jenny Gibbons. She is the CAPCOM for today. She is a backup Artemis II crew member. Those
calls from pilot Victor Glover asking about a feature he was seeing, specifically a crater
on the moon. Meanwhile, the team here in the science evaluation room was actively working
together to determine which feature he was describing. The teams at the window have continued
to move through their targets, including Ohm, Aristarchus Plateau, Reiner Gamma, and we
are preparing for the cabin and window teams to swap.
That's when we'll hear more from Reid Wiseman and Jeremy Hansen when they take on the support
roles while Christina Koch and Victor Glover are at the windows photographing and annotating.
As we briefly mentioned, if you look towards the right side of the moon, essentially, this
live view coming from a camera outside the Orion spacecraft and if you look on
the right side of the moon where you see those dark patches wow yeah but the
terminator right now is just fantastic it is the most rugged that I've seen it
from a lighting perspective there are little islands there are islands of
terrain out there that are completely surrounded by darkness which indicates
some real variation up to the north there is a then on the southern edge
there's almost like a hole looks like a hole and it's a diameter of Avalon and
then a wall of not a nice smooth out the pole is not only a very look again looks
like just a deep hole and then there's like two integrity science oh my gosh
that was an amazing picture you just painted I glanced over at the serve
video and I literally saw fist pumps in the air those types of observations are
things that humans are uniquely able to contribute and you just really brought
us along with you so thanks for that
Christina this is Houston we did not but we will take it now
went to window three, and the one at window three went to window two when they swapped.
Copy, Christina. That makes sense to us, and good plan. We are coming up here on a cabin and window
team swap. Let me know when you're ready for a quick vehicle status. As you heard, science.
Go for the vehicle system update. Howdy, Reid. We don't have much for you. We just wanted to let
you know that toilet right now is no-go for use as we stick with the predetermined limit.
for now. All crew members, please use CCUs. Otherwise, Orion is looking very good. And
you have 15 minutes in this handover time where we expect Victor and Christina to switch
to the windows and you and Jeremy to be in the cabin assisting. Let us know if you have
any questions.
It's the same darkness, if not a little darker than Grimaldi, but it's cool after just being at the 400 mil for the last...
We love it. We are getting a sneak preview from one of our SAW cameras of what you're looking at, and we see some of what you are describing.
We cannot wait to see your photos. Thanks.
Alright, MPO and INCO, take notes. We want a zoom lens on those SAWs next time. Thanks, Reed.
As the crew gets ready to switch positions from the window crew going back to the support crew
and the support crew flying up to the windows, this view inside the room,
Capcom Jenny Gibbons speaking with the crew, Canadian Space Agency astronaut.
The crew has continued to provide excellent descriptions
of what they are seeing on the lunar surface.
In this picture or in this live view actually from Orion and a camera mounted
on its solar array wing if you look at the dark portion on the right side of the screen
those are visible from earth that's considered the near side
those are ancient lava flows from a time early in the moon's history when it was
volcanically active if you look towards the left there's that dark large crater that appears above
to the left of those lava flows that's oriental basin it's about 600 miles wide
and it straddles the moon's near and far side and this mission is the first time that humans
have ever been able to see this with their eyes in the daylight again you hear conversation about
that terminator you have a great view of that as well that's the difference between light and
darkness on the moon victor glover explaining that as a very jagged looking terminator due to the
peaks that they're seeing and the craters that they're seen as they prepare to cross over the
far side you also heard science officer the dr kelsey young artemis science flight operations
lead sharing with victor glover that his responses are truly something that only human eyes can
discern or provide so we've previously discussed how having humans observing the moon on this
mission is being combined with lunar robotic data to help us maximize what we know about the moon
So part of that data comes from the Lunar Reconnaissance Orbiter, or LRO.
This orbiter provides the robotic foundation that makes Artemis II lunar science possible.
LRO has been orbiting the Moon for 17 years, which makes it the longest-operated lunar
orbiter in history, and it's also the only American spacecraft dedicated specifically
to lunar science and exploration.
Artemis II Lunar Observations are designed to complement data like the detailed surface
images from LRO.
So while LRO provides those detailed, high-resolution maps of the Moon's surface, the Artemis II
crew adds human observations that focus on regional context and relationships between
features, giving scientists a larger geologic picture.
This combination of robotic and human observations strengthens lunar science.
LRO delivers precise and repeatable measurements over long periods of time, while the Artemis
crew contributes real-time visual descriptions and context that robotic instruments alone
cannot provide.
The best description I've heard while preparing for this mission is to compare the difference
in looking at the Moon with your own eyes on Earth and trying to take a picture with
a camera.
The camera truly never does it justice, and it's much easier to describe and perceive
what you're seeing with your own eye than to take a photo.
These Artemis II astronauts can rapidly scan wide areas and adjust their focus in real
time, as well as describe relationships between features.
The crew will also observe the same regions multiple times under changing lighting conditions
during the flyby and provide perspectives that would take robotic missions years to
accumulate.
During the Artemis II mission, LRO is also attempting to observe some of the same lunar
features that the astronauts are studying.
Collecting this data simultaneously highlights how different instruments and human eyes provide
complementary information about the Moon.
This LRO data plays a direct role in preparing for future Artemis missions.
Its measurements of topography, surface temperature, composition, radiation, and lighting conditions
are used to assess hazards, identify safe landing sites, and locate potential resources
such as water ice near the lunar south pole.
This mission, Artemis II, represents the point where years of robotic preparation are paired
with human exploration for the first time in the Artemis era.
So together, LRO, the Lunar Reconnaissance Orbiter, and Artemis II are demonstrating
how NASA moved from mapping the moon robotically to exploring it with humans.
We are laying the groundwork for future Artemis missions and sustained lunar operations.
A check-in with Orion, we are now four days, 21 minutes, four days,
21 hours, and 22 minutes into the flight of Artemis II,
our crew aboard the Orion spacecraft.
We are now 8,153 miles away from the moon,
250,742 miles away from Earth.
The spacecraft is traveling at 1,030 miles per hour.
One with the long lens.
Copy, I'll read, we like it.
As we heard confirmation from NASA astronaut and commander of Artemis II Reid Wiseman,
they are now switching positions of the support teams and the observation teams.
So initially, Reid Wiseman and Jeremy Hansen were at Windows 2 and 3
in the Orion spacecraft taking photos and making annotations
in their PCDs, portable computing devices.
They were also giving audible descriptions into their PCDs, wearing headsets with microphones
and providing recordings that the science team will be able to listen to later.
We were hearing from NASA astronauts Christina Koch and Victor Glover
as they made observations as part of the support team.
Now as these teams are swapping, we anticipate hearing more from Reid and Jeremy
as they'll be on the support team, while Victor and Christina will be at the windows taking photos
and making annotations.
Four to block out the ambient, let's see any difference.
Copy, read, we're taking note and we'd be curious too.
We are live in the Artemis Mission Control Room during the lunar flyby of the Artemis II crew,
the first humans to fly by the moon in over 50 years.
Orion launched four days, 21 hours and 30 minutes ago atop the SLS rocket space
Space Launch System rocket from Kennedy Space Center in Florida.
Our four crew members inside the spacecraft are transitioning their positions.
The cabin and window teams have swapped.
Currently at the window, we have Victor Glover and Christina Koch, NASA astronauts, and serving
and serving as support, Reid Wiseman and Jeremy Hansen.
For our crews at the window they are using handheld Nikons with an 80-400mm zoom lens.
There are also GoPros on each of the solar arrays on Orion, and that's where this view
is coming from right now.
We have an interior camera of the crew as well, but they have dimmed the cabin lights.
They've actually turned off the cabin lights to allow them to better see outside of the
spacecraft.
This also helps prevent any reflections from lights inside the spacecraft reflecting onto
reflecting onto the windows while they are photographing the moon.
We talked a little bit about the views and the cameras being used on the Orion spacecraft.
And again, we do have GoPros on the tip of each solar array wing.
Now, the bandwidth is a little bit limited because having a crew on board, we do
have to downlink a lot more data that includes their environmental control and
life support system.
We are not the only data, this view that you see, coming down from the spacecraft.
And so we do rely on sharing some of that with the other flight controllers in
mission control.
This helps the team monitor all systems aboard the spacecraft and ensure the safety of our astronauts.
We are standing by for a situation report from the crew aboard the spacecraft.
They've been imaging the whole moon. There is now a new crew at the window.
That would be Victor Glover and Christina Koch.
And so being it's their first time since they have moved up to the window positions,
They have a chance to orient themselves and describe and take pictures of any color or albedo variations across the surface.
Reminder, albedo is the brightness or reflectiveness.
Integrity science for a science sit rep when you're ready.
With the long lens.
Integrity, we copy.
Are the shrouds still on windows one and four?
And if so, would you consider trying to get a view through one of those windows?
The docking hatch window.
So I can see Oriental south down to the south pole.
You can see from Oriental right now is just the long trenches at the ejecta.
Science, that was a great description.
Thank you, and thanks for the docking window geometry to give us that description.
Any comments before you go on the annular ring in Oriental?
Everybody kind of just read.
That's exactly what we were looking for.
Thanks so much.
You have heart hands coming out of the CER.
Just saying that the CER was really excited about that,
that annular ring was something we were really eager to hear about, so thanks.
That was NASA astronaut Reid Wiseman now providing a science SIP rep
as he is away from the windows most of the time.
He is working as the support person along with Jeremy Hansen in the spacecraft
as Victor Glover and Christina Koch are now at windows two and three,
able to photograph the moon.
Christina and Victor are also providing recorded information
to their portable computing devices, that's their PCDs,
and the science team will have access to that at a later time.
They will then review it and compile all of this data
to help further our understanding of the moon.
One of the items you heard mentioned was Oriental Basin.
This has been a very exciting opportunity for the crew.
They have all been very excited about seeing Oriental as well
as the science team has been looking forward to it.
It is known as the Grand Canyon of the Moon
as we discussed earlier from the pictures the science team is hoping that the crew will take
centered images of the entire basin and surrounding craters in a single frame
but also use those 80 to 400 millimeter zoom lenses to create a mosaic
entire basin with their unaided eyes the science team
is hoping the crew will describe southern dark annual ring which you heard
read just describing, as well as any color, albedo, texture,
or topography across the Mare Patches and Ring Mountains.
Science team reports that the observations will be used
to study the geologic evolution of the youngest lunar basin
and to inform formation hypotheses
for the annular ring.
And again, another fun fact about Oriental is the diameter
is the same distance between Johnson Space Center,
where we are today, and Kennedy Space Center,
where the crew launched on april 1st this live view from the orion spacecraft on the artemis
ii mission now 7 373 miles away from the moon 251 130 miles from earth again the Artemis ii crew
passed the apollo 13 record of the humans farthest from the earth today at 12 57 p.m central time
1 57 p.m eastern time that distance set by apollo 13 was 248 655 statute miles
we have clearly passed that and we expect to pass that by about 4 105 miles
that'll been when that will be when the spacecraft reaches its farthest distance from the earth it
It could be around 252,760 miles, but again, these are approximations and are targets,
and we will make sure to report back the final numbers once we have them.
We have some refined times of when we expect to have Earth set of Earth behind the moon
while Orion flies behind the moon.
That would be about 5.41 p.m. Central, 6.41 Eastern.
The spacecraft would make its closest approach to the moon
at 6 o'clock Central, 7 Eastern.
And that would be about 4,066 miles.
And then at 6.02 p.m. Central.
And the spacecraft will reach its farthest distance
from the Earth.
We anticipate that will be about 252,755 miles,
which would be 4,111 miles farther than Apollo 13.
We would see Earth rise again at 6.21 p.m. Central Time, and a few moments later,
a few minutes later, regain communications with the crew.
Currently aboard Orion, Victor Glover and Christina Koch are the two team members
conducting lunar flyby observations, meaning they are using the Nikon cameras to photograph the moon
and their PCD, or the Portable Computing Device, to conduct annotations.
They are both recording information that will be downlinked to the science crew.
And tomorrow morning, the science team will have a conference with the team while the information is so fresh.
They'll be speaking with the crew about their observations and their data collection.
Otherwise, most of tomorrow, Flight Day 7, is considered an off day.
We are on Flight Day 6 of the Artemis II mission,
the first time in more than 50 years that humans will observe the moon directly,
providing a critical opportunity to practice how lunar science will be conducted during future Artemis missions.
If you're just joining us, the crew is well into their lunar flyby observations,
and we anticipate that we will hear from them soon.
A few times every hour, they are slated to call down with science sit-reps or situation reports.
We most recently had one from Commander Reid Wiseman.
He and Jeremy Hansen, Mission Specialist, were first at the windows today to photograph and make annotations of what they were seeing.
Therefore, we heard more from Victor Glover and Christina Koch earlier in the day during those first blocks.
But now that Reid Wiseman and Jeremy Hansen are on the support side, they are the ones calling down what they are seeing from Windows 1 and 4.
Earlier, we heard that the Earth is so bright in window 4 they have had to temporarily cover
it with a t-shirt.
The moon preserves a near continuous record of solar system history that has been erased
on Earth because the moon doesn't have an atmosphere.
So things that we experience on Earth like weather or plate tectonics don't really apply.
So the lunar surface retains evidence of ancient impacts, volcanism, and solar activity that
scientists can study today.
And studying the Moon helps scientists understand how planets formed and evolved, how the Moon
influenced our own planet Earth's history, and how the Sun shaped conditions across the
inner solar system.
The Moon also serves as a unique platform for studying the broader universe.
Artemis Science is designed around questions best answered by humans, working alongside
robotic systems, combining decades of robotic lunar data with real-time judgment, context,
adaptability that only humans can provide.
This mission, Artemis II, is serving as a proving ground for lunar science operations,
which allows NASA to test how science is planned, executed, and supported during a crewed deep
space mission ahead of our future Artemis flights.
Integrity, time for a window team position swap.
So Victor and Christina, please switch places if you've not done so already, and remember
your SD card for the camera.
And I'll switch over and change guards in the long lens.
Copy.
As you heard in that call, it is now time for the team members at the window to swap positions.
That means Victor Glover and Christina Koch will be switching roles.
One of them has been photographing the moon with a Nikon with an 80 to 400 millimeter zoom lens,
while the other was making annotations on their portable computing device.
and both are recording audio that the science team will be able to listen to we are now two
hours and 10 minutes until we expect to lose signal with the spacecraft as they fly behind
the moon and the next target for the crew is considered a crew choice event they have the
option to focus on any regions or patterns or features that interest them the science team has
asked the crew to capture pictures that illustrate their choice as well as at different zoom levels
and to describe why those certain features or regions caught their eye those recordings are
part of what are being saved on their pcds portable computing device that will be sent
to the science team for analysis the crew has been allotted eight minutes for this crew choice event
and it's also a time for a scheduled sit rep or situation report so we expect to hear them
calling down what they are seeing soon something that the crew or that the
science team has used to help prepare the crew is a cue card these ask for a
feature ID if they happen to know the type or name and if it is a target of
course in this situation when they have a crew choice they do not need to it may
or may not be a target they want to know the location and the observation style
they've also asked for the geometry of what's being captured the size shape
boundary and preservation as well as the color and shadow so the color tone the
albedo that reflection or brightness and any shadows or illumination next they're
interested in structure and texture that includes slopes structures and textures
of course and geologic relations like association to other features any
contact to those features and of course their thoughts impressions or
interpretations. They are interested even in emotions and excitement that the crew
may be having. This fly-by day has been practiced in many ways even in sims here
in Mission Control Houston. The team also conducted some fieldwork learning how to
look for specific geologic features. They also photographed a large globe and the
The science team helped them determine which features they would be targeting and how to
look at those.
We have a few more minutes that the crew would be photographing their crew choice.
Again, this is NASA astronauts Victor Glover and Christina Koch at the windows.
They will then move on to another discussion portion.
This is for the far side albedo, that reflectiveness and color that they are seeing.
We heard earlier about some browns seen on the moon, which is very interesting, especially
here from Earth where we are just seeing whites, grays and maybe even black at
some points. When they get into that discussion for a far south far side
albedo in a few minutes the theme is looking to know how that color and albedo
is what those variations look like across the far side. On the right side of
your screen the science evaluation room or SIR where team members are looking
real time at what the crew is seeing and even earlier we're we'll take it about the resolution
the long lens looking at the window and i'm sneaking a look a peek in t-shirt window
it looks like on the limb of the it's amazing how quickly it changes as we stuff that's leaving our
field of view missing for us right now jeremy science thanks for that sit rep um do you have
a question. A few times we've heard you and the other crew describe change during the course of
your flyby. Would be interested in future descriptions of more verbosity about how it's
changing. Thanks for the great sitrep. Right. When you come back to the window, I was just in the
interior. It's just from this window, but I will talk about something that I was talking a lot
about from this window. I see a lot of these, what I would call brownish hue areas. There's a number
of them. It looks like that is a lighter albedo, but in between the rays where the is causing the
brown to me. So I saw that in the northwest side of Aristarchus area of the highland, the east of
Glushko. And then I see those huge region with the point of the pie pointing at Oriental and then
going up towards that is a... That was fantastic, Jeremy. We had heard rumors of the green and brown
Hughes and so you really read my mind on asking about those understand they
likely didn't have any contact with each other the way that you described them
but please correct me if I misunderstood that and then last thing I'll make the
same offer we made to Victor earlier if it would be helpful for us to verbalize
any targets so you can stay at the windows and keep your eyes adjusted to
the moon please let us know definitely not looking to interrupt your flow read
and Jeremy only offering assistance if you guys want
to keep your eyes off of the PCDs.
Read, Houston copies and we were commenting
on the same thing even from our view.
The Terminator looks absolutely alien because there's just
so much texture in there that we're just not used to seeing.
So thanks for sharing that with us.
That's right.
It's the southernmost.
We're looking for you.
We're loving that picture.
Thanks for showing us and read as an answer
to your last question.
And we believe that that is Chebyshev Crater.
And the sir agrees with that.
We love it.
This is Artemis Mission Control in Houston, Texas.
Control in Houston, Texas. Mission elapsed time, four days, 22 hours, 12 minutes into the flight of Orion.
This is Lunar Flyby Day for the crew aboard the spacecraft.
Reid Wiseman, Victor Glover, Christina Koch, and Jeremy Hansen are now the farthest people
to have ever traveled from Earth.
a live view from inside the spacecraft.
They have turned off the lights so they're able to see outside
and photograph the moon better with no reflections from inside.
And for a very brief moment there.
Integrity Science, thanks for those iPhone views.
Uh-huh. It's helpful to see what you're seeing.
We very briefly saw NASA astronaut Reid Wiseman showing a picture he took
on his phone of the moon.
We do expect to get all of the photos that the crew is taking today, and we cannot wait to share some of those with you.
But pretty cool in the meantime, just to see one quick shot from what the crew is seeing.
And this view from outside the spacecraft on Orion's solar array wing.
Orion is now 6,643 miles away from the moon and continuing to grow closer.
Again, their closest approach will be about 4,066 miles.
The best comparison is if you held a basketball at arm's length.
That's about what it would look like to the Artemis II crew at their closest approach.
This view showing at the very top a camera coming from Orion continuing their flyby of
the moon.
We have three more flyby observation blocks after the completion of this one.
Down on the bottom left of your screen, that's the SUR, the Science Evaluation Room where
team members are continuing to work through all of the targets that the crew is photographing
today and they've helped identify some of the craters and some of the other items that
the crew has seen on the moon's surface.
Down on the right is Artemis Mission Control here in Houston.
Those two rooms down at the bottom are just down the hall from each other.
we are just a few minutes away from the next cabin and window team swap that
means Victor and Christina who have been at the windows will fly to the cabin the
background essentially and be their support crew for Reed and Jeremy read
Jeremy will move back up to the windows the crew is continuing their discussion
portion of the flyby in the lunar targeting package where it says far side
albedo slash color they are looking the science team looking to get a good
understanding of what the crew can see on the far side at this point and its
brightness as well as any colors we did hear earlier and Canadian Space Agency
astronaut Jeremy Hansen reporting that they could even see Browns and even
greens on the moon I'm really looking forward to seeing those photos and in
just a couple of minutes the teams will swap from the cabin to the window
another rundown of just how this flied-by is choreographed inside the
spacecraft today so these activities have been timeline and there are these
five blocks of time during which the crew is going to be observing the moon
from Orion's windows now we are just coming up on the end of the second block
and we'll start the third soon so at any time during those blocks two members are
at the windows working in a pair one is taking photos from window two and has a
blue shroud over the window to help prevent any reflections from inside the spacecraft
they are also using an 80 to 400 millimeter zoom lens and the other astronaut on the window team
will be in window 3 using their portable computing device to make annotations
now again both of those crew members are making audio recordings of what they are seeing and we
are not hearing that right now those are going to be downlinked later to the science team who will
evaluate them and use that data to inform our understanding of the moon
those two crew members at the windows swap roles integrity houston it is time for another swap
between the cabin and the window teams so we have 15 minutes of handover time and then we will
expect Jeremy and Reed at the windows and Christina and Victor at the cabin I
have no new vehicle updates for you but I do have a photo location for some
photos on Ike's PCD and I want to let you know that Jeremy's family have arrived
in the viewing gallery okay copy all I meant to pass for Victor's PCD is that
There are some late load photos that were requested that are now
in his favorite photos folder.
And you're exactly right.
We have Catherine and Devin here.
They give you a big wave and they're super excited and happy
to see part of what you're seeing.
And we may be calling you back about that one.
All right, that's no problem and it's unrelated to flyby.
This is Artemis Mission Control here at Johnson Space Center
in Houston, Texas.
And as you just heard, CAPCOM, or Capsule Communicator,
Jenny Gibbons, Canadian Space Agency astronaut and Artemis II crew backup relaying to the
teams in Orion that it is time for a swap from the cabin to the window teams.
We're now at the tail end of the second Lunar Flyby Observation Block.
Again, we have five of these today.
Most recently, Victor Glover and Christina Koch were at the windows photographing and
making annotations, while Reid Wiseman and Jeremy Hansen were in the cabin providing
support, whether that is SD card help, but also science sit reps calling down any situation
reports for what they are seeing on the moon or anything about the vehicle's status.
With that call to make a swap, Reid and Jeremy will be back at the windows making observations
for what they see at the moon and taking photos.
Again, you're watching live coverage of NASA's Artemis II.
But something that's really awesome up here is we now have the moon and the earth
in window three simultaneously.
That is pretty darn cool.
That's the Artemis II crew, the first astronauts to fly by the moon in more
than 50 years, reporting that when they look out of window three, one window,
they're able to see both the earth and the moon at the same time now.
Now obviously our view is from a camera on the solar array wing pointed at the moon.
and we hope to see that view of both the Earth and the Moon soon.
Some upcoming times for what you can expect.
In about an hour and 40 minutes, we will have Earth set,
and during that time we will have a view of Earth going behind the Moon.
Shortly after, just a few minutes later, we will lose signal with the Orion spacecraft.
This is tracked as it is going behind the moon and out of reach of the deep space network.
At 6 o'clock p.m., the spacecraft will make its closest approach
to the moon at a distance of about 4,066 miles.
At 6.02 central, the spacecraft will reach its farthest distance
from Earth at about 252,755 miles.
Of course, these are approximate, and we will make sure to provide you
with the final distances once those are confirmed.
At 6.21 p.m., we will have Earthrise from the Orion spacecraft, but we will not have communications with the spacecraft until 6.25 p.m. Central when we expect to acquire signal with them after they've emerged from behind the moon.
Again, you're watching live coverage of NASA's Lunar Flyby for the Artemis II mission, the first crew to fly beyond the moon in over 50 years.
The astronauts inside the spacecraft are switching positions, two at the windows and two serving
in support roles, before they start their third Timeline Flyby Observation for today.
We've heard great calls from the crew so far describing what they're seeing, all well-trained
by the science team here on the ground.
Another major milestone for the crew today will be to experience a solar eclipse from
their capsule.
No one on Earth will experience this solar eclipse.
To the astronauts, this will look a lot like a total solar eclipse on Earth, except the
Moon will be huge compared to the Sun.
Whereas if you're standing on Earth and looking at a solar eclipse, the Moon and the Sun appear
to be about the same size in the sky.
As the Moon begins to cover and then uncover the Sun, the astronauts will see a partial
solar eclipse, so that's before and after totality.
And during that time frame they will have to wear eclipse glasses so they can safely
view this phase.
They also intend to capture images of the sun's corona during the eclipse.
This is a rare glimpse at the innermost corona that will only be captured by the astronauts
cameras.
During the eclipse we also look forward to the crew members describing what they will
see which includes unique light features like the shape and size of the corona and potentially
even lunar dust.
At the same time, Venus, Saturn, Mars and Mercury will be near the Sun, so they may
be able to identify what part of the sky they are looking at.
This can help train future Artemis astronauts on what part of sky they are seeing, which
is useful knowledge in challenging situations when they may need to rely on that information
instead of instruments for navigation and orientation.
That eclipse window will last about an hour and it will happen near the end of the day
today, closer to 735 p.m. Central, 835 Eastern.
As you can see in this live view from Orion, the spacecraft is maneuvering around the moon
and the views of the moon have changed since we started our broadcast.
The near side is now very far to the right side of your screen.
of your screen. This is the side that we can see from Earth. That darkened portion are ancient lava flows.
The crater down towards the bottom of the moon is Oriental and this is a crater that
was previously never seen before by human eyes until this mission.
Everything to the left of Oriental is considered the far side and this is what we typically
do not see from Earth.
Just a reminder about this view, this is coming from a GoPro camera mounted on the tip of
one of Orion's four solar arrays.
Each solar array has a camera mounted on it, and the bandwidth is limited due to we have
a crew on board, and this is our first flight of crew aboard the Orion spacecraft, so having
a crew means we have to have an environmental control and life support system.
There's a lot of data around, a lot of to bring down for the crew members to keep us
up to date on everything happening aboard the spacecraft, so we have to share our bandwidth
when it comes to imagery and data.
Inside the Orion spacecraft,
the astronauts have completed their cabin
and window team swap, meaning we have moved into the next block
of lunar flyby observations.
Jeremy Hansen and Reid Wiseman are now back at the windows,
taking photos and making annotations.
About halfway through this block,
they will switch positions at the windows
and will be prompted by the ground to do so.
I'll just talk, even though we have a great visible eye image, there's just a lot of texture that just pops right out at you when you can zoom in.
So almost just using it like a telescope, the camera lens.
We really enjoyed our discussion time.
That was a great innovation on the lunar table to describe a lot more kind of with flow, I would say.
What we were talking to is also we get ideas off of each other, accessible talking.
Copy those logistics for the Peltors, and also thanks for bringing us into the cabin with you with that description.
On time, NASA astronaut Christina Koch, a mission specialist for Artemis II, calling down a science SITREP, a situation report.
Good news, reporting that she and her teammates have been able to capture all targets that were listed.
Christina also gave a vibrant description of just how it feels to be there and to see the moon up close.
and not just something passing in our night sky.
Currently, the team members at the window
are Reid Wiseman and Jeremy Hansen.
Meanwhile, Integrity Cabin Team for Window Shroud.
Hey, Victor, we have a temperature constraint
on the windows, and the shroud might be getting us close,
so we just want to check on the state of Window 4's shroud,
whether you believe it's still necessary
because maybe things have changed with our viewing and if so we would like to request to have the
shroud removed unfortunately since it's been on for a while we are going to have to request that
the shroud is removed and we can recommend something that could block the light but just
create a bit of distance between the window and whatever is covering covering it something like
a t-shirt would do the trick and help uh we'll make it work thank you victor um we know it's
pretty right in there now with that window uncovered we will also offer that airflow
on the window would be helpful so if you want you can also retrieve the condensation hose
which should be friction fit onto one of the diffusers and that on the window
would also help okay we'll take that victor thank you please keep us updated
that call from capcom jenny gibbons csa astronaut and artemis ii crew backup to the crew aboard
Orion letting them know that they will need to remove the window shroud they had placed on window
four they initially placed that shroud there to block out some of the light from the earth it was
extremely bright coming in the cabin and interfering with some of their viewing opportunities
out at the moon this was a request from ground teams to ensure that they are protecting other
systems and the crew has been offered the opportunity to use something else to cover
the window.
Meanwhile, Reid Wiseman and Jeremy Hansen continue with their lunar flyby observations.
They have just looked at Glushko Crater.
That's about when we heard that call down from Christina Koch with that description
of everything she had been seeing during her observation period and what she was seeing
at that time.
The science team asked this crew to take centered images of the entire crater and their ray
system in one frame.
They're also interested in knowing the brightness, texture, and extent of Glushko's rays and
how they differ in the mare, or that sea area, versus the highlands.
Glushko is considered a young lunar crater and these observations can help understand
material properties of those craters.
Victor, thank you, you got a cheer from science there.
And we all just went on that moonwalk with you, so highlighting how important it is to talk about these things.
I also want to let you know that we have Deanna Glover with us in the viewing gallery.
She's all smiles.
We love that we got a hey, babe, too, and we also have one of your lovely daughters here watching you guys work.
To all of you, Genesis, I love you, and Deanna, I love yo.
I'm glad you get to be there.
We've had some really sweet words from the crew members aboard Orion today as
their families have been able to filter in and out of the viewing room here
at Artemis Mission Control at Johnson Space Center in Houston.
Patrick Glover also giving a great science sit rep and just a description
of how it must feel if you were down on the lunar surface while he was looking
through that 80 to 400 millimeter zoom lens. He also expressed how important it
was to be able to talk through that real time
with Christina Koch,
and stress the importance of that on future missions,
that it not only made their discussions better,
but also more human.
Glover and Cook are in the support roles right now,
not taking photos or making annotations at the windows,
but they are also encouraged
to have their midday meal at this time.
For lunch today, those two crew members have options
of beef ravioli, salmon, butternut squash,
sweet and savory kale, pickled beets, cherry blueberry cobbler, tuna noodle casserole,
tomatoes and artichokes, broccoli, and chocolate peanut butter bar. Once Glover and Cook return to
the window portion of their flyby today, Reid Wiseman and Jeremy Hansen will get into their
midday meal. Again this is the third of five scheduled blocks for our lunar viewing today and
if you were watching at the start of the broadcast you can definitely tell the difference in the
distance from the moon. We are now 5,518 miles away from the lunar surface and again expecting
the crew to get about 4,066 miles away. They are currently 252,050 miles away from earth
And every mile is a new record, having surpassed the Apollo 13 milestone for furthest distance earlier today.
If you look down to the bottom right of the moon in that darker looking area, that is Oriental Basin.
We have continued to lose views of the near side.
It is just barely visible over towards the bottom right side of your screen.
And then you'll also hear later about that Terminator.
That's the line between light and darkness.
while on the moon. It is really exposing some of those craters at this time.
A couple of the other features in view right now are Hertzsprung Basin and Vavlyov Crater.
Hertzsprung basin is nearer to the center of the moon, closer to that terminator line right now,
and Vavelyov Crater is just on the outskirts of it, closer again to the terminator. Towards the
bottom of the moon and to the left of the terminator line or currently shadowed in darkness
is apollo basin 91 mile looked like uh southernmost part of the terminater if one was running uh to
the only see about half of it i'm looking through the docking hatch window right now because we have
the z9 and window one yes i've been using babalov the whole time so it's gone uh two more babalov
A few more features are starting to peek out into the sunlight there with that one angle and so you still have ridges and Gros Maldi appears to be one of the farthest east features and that is maybe five degrees from being right on the limb and going off over the horizon.
It is interesting just looking at Oriental is all of the dark, well, it's still relatively the same to the sun, but my angle to it is different.
So I'm looking at it from a little more even further to the side as we pass here to be just a little bit lighter for this vantage point.
Thanks for that description, Ike.
Any additional words you can provide on Oriental would be wonderful as that is such a high priority target for us.
And while I have you, as we get closer to Target 15, which is the Terminator target,
if you can find Zeman Crater again that you were looking at earlier,
everything to your left of Zeman would be getting into the South Pole area to help you orient yourself.
Let's see.
Looking back at oriental.
Okay.
And then going to the 400-millimeter zone.
Now, looking at it, I see the cliff faces.
If you were standing in the center, I look at even with my naked eye,
I can tell that there's a lot of elevation and, like I said, a cliff face on that eastern edge
where all the darker deposits are.
And it's just the scale now, looking at from far away before, it seemed like,
that I look at it I can definitely see that there is you know different
depositional characteristics and so the darker is some other material but
there's also some shadowing going on because of the great description Victor
thanks and really interesting to hear now the distinction between shadow and
color before I let you go back to other observations you mentioned that Reed saw
a browner hue to the annular ring than the rest of oriental are you seeing that
from your vantage point way that I'm looking at oriental again I'm still in
the docking hatch window there's like the window so you know next to a hang
out any color that I could pick up from the moon I am not able to see that color
but I have not looked at it through one of the forward phase from one of the
windows one through four I think when I get away from this captain tape strip
that I would be able to see.
That is great feedback operationally.
Thanks, Victor.
I'll leave you to it.
From the window team.
Integrity, this is Science here with you.
Question to help inform a theory that they're tossing back and forth.
What is older, the Mare Seas of the nearside or oriental?
Stand by, Integrity.
We're going to get you a little geologic history here.
Integrity, Science, back with you for some lunar volcanism when you're ready.
You're making our day down here getting to talk about lunar volcanoes.
Orientol, as far as mare go, is younger than almost all of the mare on the near side.
The exception are features like Aristarchus, which really pop out to you guys and really pop out
to us here on Earth. That is younger. But other than that, Orientol is pretty young as far as
Marigo. And Kelsey, thanks for that. We love Leonard volcanism. Yeah, we're going to get you
an age for oriental. And while we're getting that, Christina, can you, maybe you've heard
the window team talk about the sort of contacts around oriental, but because it's that material
is so much younger. If anything pops out to you about physical relationship between that
and surrounding terrain, we'd love to hear it. Yeah, definitely. Thank you, Integrity. And I
I know Jenny wants to get to you with some topics, so I'll leave you with Oriental is 3.8 billion years old.
On the older side.
Correct, as is the case with a lot of Mare.
Typically the big basin formed, and then the volcanic eruption was able to punch through the crust
where it was weakened by that basin formation.
NASA astronaut Christina Koch calling down some questions to the science team on console.
The voice you're hearing with those answers is Dr. Kelsey Young.
She is joined by Trevor Graff on console today.
Christina asking about the age of Oriental and specifically the Mare regions.
Those are those dark regions that you see.
They are paved or filled by volcanic deposits.
Integrity, it's about time for a position swap at the window.
So we will ask Reed and Jeremy to swap positions, and I'll remind you again about your SD cards.
And Victor or Christina, I have one window task for the cabin team when you're ready.
All right, Tina, we found a way that we can reinstall the shroud on the window.
We understand it's pretty darn bright compared to everything that you're looking at.
So in order to reinstall it, we will ask that you retrieve the condensation hose
and you install it on a friction fit on the cabin air outlet port.
That's right by one of your diffusers.
You're going to point that little condensation hose such that the air is flowing over the window pane.
Let me know when you're ready for the stowage location.
Christina, the hose is in locker A1.
The crew has gotten a go to reinstall that window shroud they were using to block some
of the Earthshine.
Copy.
This view coming from inside the Orion spacecraft as the crew members are swapping
windows, specifically Reid Wiseman and Jeremy Hansen.
They've been our crew members at the windows taking photos, making annotations, and making
recordings that will be downlinked later to the science team for review.
The science team will have a conference tomorrow morning with the crew to get any fresh perspectives
or things that they learned during the flyby.
Again, we are now in the third of five observation blocks for the crew scheduled for today.
During this flyby, Orion is passing around between 4,000 and 6,000 miles from the moon
and providing the crew with a full view of the lunar surface.
It's a higher vantage point and much farther than Apollo's lunar orbits on average.
So from this view, astronauts can observe both the North and South Pole and large-scale
geologic features in one single view.
We are now just under an hour until Orion passes behind the Moon, and we lose communication
with the crew.
They will be out of reach with any of our deep space network antennas.
That loss of signal will last about 40 minutes, and we expect to regain communications with
them once they fly behind the other side of the Moon.
While they are behind the Moon, they will also reach their max Earth altitude, as well
as their closest approach to the lunar surface.
The view you have right now is a live stream from a camera on Orion's solar arrays.
You are looking at a live view of the Moon, and four people are inside that spacecraft
taking pictures of it, telling us everything that they are seeing, the first humans to do so in over
50 years. They'll be sending those pictures down for all of us to enjoy, and of course, especially
the science team, who are very excited for what they are learning today. It appears the Artemis
2 spacecraft Orion is now under 5,000 miles away from the moon. Again, we expect their closest
closest distance to the Moon be about 4,066 miles. That is an estimate at this point and
we will make sure to share that closest approach distance once we receive it.
Just want us to cool the window and then cool the window at the same time.
Victor, we definitely want you to cool down the window with the condensation hose. It's
crew preference whether you put the shroud back on. The hose will allow you to do that
if it helps with your lunar flyby.
Okay, copy. We're going to do both at the same time. Thank you.
Houston copies.
We are now seeing...
Thank you, Victor. We're happy to hear it, and we see half moon, full moon joy still.
Crew reporting from Orion that they are seeing half the moon, which is about what it looks like here from this view from the spacecraft.
However, what has become a little bit of a catchphrase for this mission, everyone is reporting full moon joy.
joy we are keeping up with which targets the crew is tracking through their lunar targeting
package they are just wrapping up their second integrity another observation uh the the window
team commented on and christine and i discussed a bit is in her strong the uh victor that's a
wonderful description going from a paved road to lava reminds us of the icelandic highlands
thanks for that. Great descriptions, Victor, thanks. Not swirly, just patchy is really
helpful for us. Really great descriptions coming from... We've been loving your evocative
descriptions, Victor. You really are bringing us along with you and we're following along
with visualizations that pale in comparison to your descriptions. Thanks. Integrity science,
One more question on a status of what the window team chose to observe for crew choice.
Window 2.
Wonderful.
And another observation about oriental is going off to the southwest.
The two large, almost look like center, almost parallel, going off southwest from oriental basin.
Love to hear it, Victor.
and you had it that those chains are actually crater rays,
secondary craters formed from the formation of Oriental.
...down the way.
But something very interesting, and again, you can see this in imagery,
but it's a whole large impact.
Fantastic, Victor.
And I'll note that we can infer that you're looking down at your freshly named Integrity Crater,
which is near the end of one of those beautiful crater rays from Oriental.
Thanks for the description.
We've been hearing some great situation reports from Victor Glover, the pilot of the Artemis II
mission, calling down to the science team, letting them know what he is seeing. And one of those
things is Hertzsprung Basin. If you look just to the right of the Terminator, that is the difference
between light and darkness on the moon. You can see what he's describing when he says Hertzsprung
basin and how it looks a little bit paved in the middle there it's almost in the very center of the
moon in this view coming from the orion spacecraft and a camera mounted on its solar array we are now
four days 23 hours and 23 minutes into the flight of artemis 2 and we are standing by for their
lunar loss of signal in about 43 minutes again the spacecraft will fly behind the moon and during
that time we won't have communication with them they will be out of reach of our deep space network
however we will regain communication with them approximately 40 4-0 minutes later when they come
around the other side of the moon the crew aboard the spacecraft are currently discussing the
terminator that difference between day and night the science team is interested in learning about
the topography and the color of the lunar surface and it's already been very interesting to hear
that they have seen colors like greens and browns while looking at the moon.
Some of the questions that they are hoping the crew will discuss are
how do the quantities and sizes of craters and mountains vary along the Terminator,
and they are looking for the crew to describe the topography of features along or near the Terminator.
They're also looking for more information on any color or tone variations,
and they're hoping that the crew will take images to illustrate their findings.
Glover reported earlier that the crew has missed none of their targets when they are
photographing at the window.
We aren't hearing the conversations that the crew is having right now, but these are being
recorded to their personal computer devices, PCDs, and those will be sent down to the science
team.
The science team will have a conference with the crew tomorrow morning to discuss their
findings and experience when looking at the moon today.
We have a few minutes left while the crew is discussing the terminator, and if you're
just joining us you're looking at a live view of the moon our moon from the orion spacecraft
and a camera on its solar array inside that spacecraft four astronauts reid wiseman victor
glover Christina Koch and jeremy hansen the first four people to fly around the moon in over 50
years this is our lunar flyby day and the crew has already surpassed one record today
The crew passed the Apollo 13 distance record at 12.57 p.m. Central, 1.57 p。m. Eastern.
Canadian Space Agency astronaut Jeremy Hansen calling down that he hopes it's a record soon broken by other explorers.
We are live in Artemis Mission Control in Houston, Texas, monitoring the flight of Artemis II.
All of the flight controllers here each monitoring a different system aboard the Orion spacecraft.
Integrity Houston, we are ready for our cabin and window teams to swap again.
We have a 15 minute handover time here and I have a couple of items I want to read up to you.
They'll require you to write something down on your knee boards, so let me know when you're ready.
Copy Integrity, first of all, once you start this next shift here,
shift here. During this lunar observation shift, we will begin our lunar LOS, so you can expect
a call from me a few minutes prior reminding you. And second of all, FIDO just sent us updated
altitudes and METs for lunar closest approach and max Earth altitude. Let me know when you are
ready to write those down. They differ slightly from Optimus. Lunar closest approach will be at
At MET, 5 days, 0 hours, 25 minutes, 34 seconds, and the altitude will be 4,067 statute miles.
Earth altitude will be at MET five days, zero hours, two seven minutes, three nine seconds
with an altitude of 252,756 statute miles.
I'll send FIDO to work, and I appreciate the metric.
Other than that, I have no new vehicle statuses to pass to you.
Enjoy your handover time, and we're looking forward to picking back up with you shortly.
Those words called from CAPCOM Jenny Gibbons, CSA astronaut,
and Artemis II backup crew member to the crew working aboard the Orion spacecraft.
Had a little bit of a view inside the cabin.
As you can see, it is very dark.
The crew has turned off the lights,
and the light that you were able to see is coming through the window a reflection of earth shine and
from the moon the crew is moving into their next observation block meaning they are taking time to
switch cabin and window teams we've had Reid Wiseman and jeremy hansen at the windows taking
pictures and making annotations and recording some audio files that will be downlinked later
to the science team meanwhile victor glover and Christina Koch were in the background serving as
support they were also timeline to enjoy a little bit of their midday meal now
that we are swapping positions the support team becomes Reid Wiseman and
Jeremy Hansen they will be in the background helping with SD card swaps as
well as providing those situational reports to the science team Victor
Glover and Christina Koch will be the astronauts at the window photographing
and speaking into those PCDs, portable computing devices, about what they're seeing on the
moon.
As you heard Capcom Jenny Gibbons call to the crew, this block is also when we will
lose communications with the crew.
That LOS, or loss of signal, is scheduled to be less than 35 minutes from now.
We anticipate to be out of signal with them for about 40 minutes and will regain that
communication once they've flown around the other side of the moon.
Now, even though the crew will be flying behind the moon, their observation period does not stop.
They will still be taking pictures and making annotations of what they are seeing.
They'll be looking for the limb of the moon, Earth set, and then a Vavilov crater, which we have previously seen.
They'll swap positions at the window before moving into a crew choice option.
They will get to pick things that are interesting to them on the surface, take pictures, and explain why they find them that way.
They'll also be looking for any impact flashes.
These are short-lived flashes on the lunar surface caused by impact bombardment.
Just before Earthrise, the crew will be looking for lofted lunar dust.
This may be lofted just above the lunar surface, and we could only see it just before Earthrise along the dark western limb.
Any Earth shine would illuminate potential lofted dust, but once the crew is all the way around the Earth,
the brightness of the Earth will wash out any of that dust they might be able to see.
These were based on observations from Apollo missions, an orbital spacecraft,
and so we're very interested to see if the crew might be able
to capture some of that lunar dust today.
Following that lofted lunar dust target, the next will be Earthrise.
We will regain communications with the crew shortly after Earthrise.
There will be a short observation break period where the Moon is not in view.
That's because we are also anticipating the crew seeing an eclipse today.
The Moon won't be in view because the team here in Mission Control Houston will need
to change the attitude of the spacecraft and ensure that its solar arrays are gathering
light from the sun heading into that eclipse period so we will have communication with the
crew we just won't be able to see the moon however we will have views during that eclipse time frame
during that time the science team is looking to know they it will only be illuminated by earth
shine at that point so they want to know what the whole moon looks like overall but they also want
crew to look into deep space and potentially see if they can spot any planets once the eclipse is
over the lunar flyby period will have ended we are live through the whole thing and even once flight
flyby is over today we remain live 24 7 on nasa's youtube go ahead back your way shortly thanks
jeremy i hear uh they are watching and your family is still here so thanks for passing that along
This view inside the Orion spacecraft and it's a little hard to make out but
on the left there that is Jeremy Hansen just calling down some well wishes to
his family joining us in the viewing room and watching online. Currently in
the window are Victor Glover and Christina Koch. They are taking pictures
outside of the window as they are now in their flyby observation block. At this
time Reid Wiseman and jeremy hansen are serving as support crew members and they are also going
to have an opportunity to enjoy their midday meal at this time on the lunch menu today for
reed wisemen and jeremy hatson we have vegetarian chili salmon croquettes chicken with peanut sauce
sweet and savory kale pickled beets chocolate pudding barbecued beef brisket spaghetti and meat
sauce italian vegetables butternut squash candy coated chocolates and maybe even a little bit of
coffee and if you look closely you can see it looks like they are getting into some of their
food for the midday meal all of the food on the spacecraft is rehydratable we don't have an option
for fresh food as there's not a refrigerated section of the orion spacecraft so all of this
food can either be rehydrated or eaten straight from the package just depends on what the food
actually is and for food that needs to be rehydrated there is information on
each package of how much water needs to fill that bag and what temperature it
needs to be we are now four days 23 hours and 39 minutes 40 minutes actually
into the flight of Artemis to the spacecraft now under 4500 miles from the
moon we are now also under 30 minutes away from loss of signal with the
astronauts we will regain that communication about 40 minutes later
they will still be photographing the moon and documenting what they're seeing
while they're behind the moon and we especially look forward to potential
Earth set and Earth rise views as you can see on the left side of your screen
we are streaming this solar array camera view throughout the flyby and the
science team also plans to capture an occasional still photo with the solar
array intermittently, perhaps one every eight to ten minutes. Still photos
represent the highest resolution imagery from those GoPro cameras. So starting
five minutes before Earth set and loss of signal, the science team will capture
a series of photos, one every 30 seconds, to include Earth set all the way through
five minutes after Earthrise and acquisition of signal. In order to
capture these frequent photos, the solar array camera that we were streaming will
need to switch to time-lapse photo mode so during this time the streaming video
quality won't be as sharp as you have it right now but we want to ensure that the
science team captures the data they need during these time frames and we really
look forward to seeing those higher resolution images once they're available
but with the few you are seeing right now we are sharing bandwidth on the
Orion spacecraft with every system that is keeping the spacecraft powered and
the crew alive especially the environmental control and life support system as this is the
first flight with crew this is also the first flight of a life support system keeping the crew
healthy and safe on the way to the moon and the way home. On the timeline we're getting towards
the end of the cabin and window team swap period but it looks like our astronauts Victor Glover
and Christina Koch are already photographing the moon outside of those windows. The next target is
om crater and this is something that they have photographed previously during the flyby this
is a small complex crater with a prominent ray system and as referenced earlier it's the size
of the eye of the sahara that eye of the Sahara is a feature in Mauritiania seeing this crater
more than once throughout the flyby allows the crew to photograph it at different lighting
conditions those different lighting conditions help expose different portions of the target
and can help the science team learn a little bit more about how it formed and what it is today.
Again, this view inside the spacecraft as the crew continues photographing the moon outside their windows.
They have turned the lights off to allow them to better get photos of the moon,
preventing any reflections from coming in from the spacecraft.
We expect the crew to be targeting Ulm crater for another six minutes or so before they
move into a discussion of the LEM.
Now the science team has asked for a science SITREP or situation report during that time
so we hope to hear calls from the crew on what they are observing.
If you've been following along, at the start of the day we did have much more of the moon
visible.
And even just an hour or so ago we could see about half of the moon.
We are now continuing to see more of the far side and that darkness where the moon is not
reflecting light from the sun.
Earlier we were also able to see some of those darker portions, that old lava flow that we
often see on the near side of the moon and that we can all see from Earth.
That has mostly gone away.
We are now just seeing very little of Oriental that's down to the bottom right of the moon.
can see just a small dark portion near the limb. We are now about 18 minutes
away from loss of signal with the Orion crew. Again we use the deep space network
to communicate with the crew members when they are this far from Earth. This
is the first mission since Apollo when we have had humans on the deep space
network. As you recently heard a Capcom Jenny Gibbons call to the crew we expect
their closest approach to the moon to be at met or mission elapsed time of five days 25 hour 25
minutes and 34 seconds at that time their altitude would be 4067 statute miles above the earth's
surface just over two minutes later they will reach their maximum distance from earth at mission
elapsed five minutes five days 27 minutes and 39 seconds the altitude at that time would be 252
2,756 statute miles. These are our latest numbers and we'll make sure to verify and confirm those
once those milestones have been achieved. Obviously we will be without communication
to the spacecraft at that time so once we regain communication we will make sure to
find out those numbers and report those to you. Checking in on the lunar targeting package the
crew is now in their discussion of the limb seeing the limb of the moon that
illuminated part currently at the windows taking photos and making
annotations are Victor Glover and Christina Koch we are expecting loss of
signal in about 13 minutes we will regain that signal with the crew about
40 minutes later a milestone worth mentioning that this day marks the first
first time in more than 50 years that humans will observe the moon directly a
critical opportunity to practice how lunar science will be conducted during
future Artemis missions I've continued to reference the lunar targeting package
throughout this broadcast which is the primary tool guiding the crew
observations and that consists of two key components the first of those is the
lunar geography review which helped the astronauts study major lunar features in
advance. That also helped them learn to orient themselves during the flyby. The
lunar targeting plan provides a detailed timeline of observation targets,
background science context, and specific instructions for the picture the crew
should take and verbal descriptions of what will be helpful to the science team
reviewing those pictures later. That's what we've been tracking real-time and
what the crew is using right now to keep up with their next milestones.
Integrity, Houston. Ten minutes till the LOS. We'll take a snappy sit rep from the cabin if you have one.
Ten minute warning for the LOS and I'll take a quick sit rep from cabin, please.
Reid's actually been trying to get some images out of the docking tunnel.
Copy, Jeremy. We'd like to know what camera Reid is using and also the status of window one. Looks like there might be a shroud removed.
Copy that makes a lot of sense to us Jeremy. I want to remind you coming up on this LOS it will take sit reps in the blind and as more and more of the moon is in darkness we will take any report you have on impact flashes.
Look out for impact flashes and we'll take sit reps on the blind.
So you understand what's going on with window one through the outer hull from window one of the vehicle when I look at your picture.
Copy.
You're getting your first live look at Orion, the Moon, and the Earth.
Everyone in this picture. This is a live view from the Orion spacecraft.
Currently aboard Orion, four crew members, Reid Wiseman, Victor Glover, Christina Koch, and Jeremy Hansen.
And on the Earth, all of us, all of humanity.
You can see the moon is starting to get a little bit dimmer as the astronauts
are going to pass behind it. Now six minutes and 26 seconds away from that
loss of signal. Again we will be out of communication with them for about 40
minutes until they come around the other side of the moon and we can re-establish
contact. Integrity Houston, you are six minutes from your 40-minute lunar flyby
LOS from all of us it's a privilege to witness you carrying the fire past our
farthest reach thank you godspeed thank you to all of you for allowing us the
immense privilege to be on this journey together this journey thinking about the
NASA mission to explore the unknown in air and space fire the world through
discovery went to the moon and farthest point from continue to unlock the
mysteries of the cosmos I would like to remind you of one of the most important
mysteries there on earth all that you are he also being a great teacher said
the second is equal to it and that is to love your neighbor down there on earth
and around earth we love you from the Houston copies we'll see on the other
side poignant words from NASA astronaut Victor Glover and a little bit of a love
letter from the other side of the moon all the way to earth. Glover touching on
the teachings of Jesus including to love your neighbor as yourself. We are now
less than three minutes away from loss of signal with the Orion astronauts. The
Artemis 2 crew will be out of signal for about 40 minutes as they are on the
other side of moon continuing their work photographing the lunar surface and they
will reemerge and we will also get this view on the other side. Just about a
minute and a half now until we lose communication with the astronauts aboard
Orion on the Artemis 2 mission. Now five days and six minutes since their launch
on April 1st. Again we'll be out of communication for about 40 minutes and
this really beautiful view of a crescent moon and a crescent Earth. How great thou
art. 30 seconds now until we expect loss of signal and we have confirmation of loss of signal of the
Orion spacecraft as it flies behind the moon. We expect to regain communications with them for
in another approximately 40 minutes. This was expected as their spacecraft is now out of direct
line of sight with earth and behind the moon and this is a poignant moment as it's the first time
in over 50 years that we have humans completely unreachable
by anyone else on Earth.
No matter how distant or secluded,
we could reach anyone living on Earth.
But while the crew flies behind the moon,
it's simply impossible to make contact with them.
This is a live view inside the Science Evaluation Room here
at Johnson Space Center and just
down the hall from Mission Control.
This team has been monitoring the science or the flyby all day
as the team has continued capturing targets on the lunar surface.
We even got to see this team in action as they were helping the astronauts identify
some of the features they were seeing on the moon but not expecting.
There will be a couple of milestones during this loss of signal.
The first will be when the astronauts make their closest approach of the moon at MET,
5 days, 25 minutes, and 34 seconds, when we expect they'll be 4,067 statute miles above
the lunar surface.
Their maximum Earth altitude will be reached just two minutes later, at 5 days, 27 minutes,
and 39 seconds, when their altitude should be approximately 252,756 statute miles.
Once those milestones are reached and we have confirmation, we will report the official
numbers.
Throughout the Artemis II mission, astronaut voice, images, video and vital mission data
must traverse thousands of miles carried on signals from NASA's powerful communications
systems, the Near Space Network and the Deep Space Network.
Let's learn a little bit more.
NASA's Artemis II will send four astronauts around the moon, preparing humanity for a
long-term lunar presence and future journeys to Mars.
Enabling communication and navigation for this test flight
are NASA's Near Space Network and Deep Space Network.
With antennas around the world and a fleet of relay satellites,
the networks will deliver vital data to and from Earth
through all phases of the mission.
The networks are seamlessly integrated
at NASA's Johnson Space Center in Houston, Texas,
where mission control coordinates the network handovers.
These transfers represent a delicate dance between the two networks,
exchanging support as the mission shoots toward the moon.
On the launch pad and during their early orbit phases,
NASA's Orion spacecraft and Space Launch System rocket
will rely on communications and tracking services from the near-space network.
After its translunar injection burn,
the deep space network's global array of antennas
will serve as Orion's primary communications support during lunar orbit.
As the mission journeys farther into space and away from Earth,
Signal strength weakens, and bandwidth is conserved for crew communications.
The astronauts will have a near-constant connection to Earth,
ensuring their safety on a journey farther into space than ever before.
We say near-constance because as Orion goes behind the moon,
a planned loss in communications will occur.
The Deep Space Network will be standing by to reacquire the signal as Orion reappears.
The Artemis II mission also provides an opportunity to test new capabilities.
Using laser links, NASA will periodically transmit Orion data
to showcase the benefits laser communications could have for future human spaceflight missions.
The data from Orion, sent by radio signals or laser links, is massive.
The mission is gathering images, data, and video,
while also generating details about mission health and crew voice files.
All of that data gets processed here on Earth, where systems compress it for efficiency.
In the future, we'll upgrade these systems on Earth so that image and video clarity improve with each moon mission.
With the Artemis II test flight, we're evaluating the communications infrastructure that will help carry us into the future as we explore the moon and journey forward to Mars.
We are now about 33 minutes until we expect to regain communications with the astronauts aboard Orion.
and in the meantime I've got Dr. Kelsey Young, Artemis Science Flight Operations Lead here with
us. Thanks for joining me Kelsey. Thanks for having me this is such an exciting day. Oh no
kidding it has been so cool to hear you communicating directly with the crew and I know
that you have been preparing for this for years so I am so excited for you and for your team. So just
to get into that background a little bit tell me about your background and what you've been doing
on console? My background is as a field geologist. Actually, I studied impact cratering in the field
for my PhD. So all these descriptions of impact craters have me just absolutely swooning.
How I got into this, though, is, you know, during my PhD, I got an internship at NASA and ultimately
never left to integrate science into flight operations. So we developed the science officer
console for which this is the first mission we're supporting. We developed the science evaluation
room that's right upstairs. And so it's so gratifying to see this operation structure
come to fruition, especially on a day like today. I would have to imagine so. And we've got a great
view of the science evaluation room right now. Is there anything that has stood out to your team so
far? Absolutely. So as you might have heard in some of the press briefings and content that,
you know, we've been putting out, color and albedo were really exciting targets for us.
We've heard several amazing color descriptions so far.
Just to highlight maybe one of them, we heard about greenish and brownish hues near Aristarchus,
which is actually a feature that we can see here from the near side.
And those greenish hues could actually tell us something about the volcanic evolution
of that area.
So you can bet that the science team is going to be prioritizing downlinking those images
and the crew audio that we didn't hear that went into those recordings to learn a little
bit more.
Wow, that is fascinating.
i was hearing those colors and very interested just from a personal standpoint because looking
at the moon from you know 250 000 miles away we don't see green or brown so just hearing that
them being so close and getting to see that fascinating and i know very exciting for you
so what are you expecting to see in the upcoming portion of the flyby the upcoming portion is uh
is actually going to be really exciting so right now as we speak um while folks in the room are
kind of taking their you know their stretch breaks and everything the crew are still hard at work
They still have targets to image and describe during this LOS.
But when we come out, the first thing, of course, we're going to hear about is Earthrise.
We're really looking forward to hearing about the cruise experience with something that we
can connect with and that, you know, Apollo 8 brought us such amazing images from.
But then we start to get into describing the Terminator, as well as looking for things
like lofted dust, which tell us about the modern lunar environment.
Then the vehicle is going to orient away from the moon for an hour and then pivot back for
the eclipse observations which is a whole different set of science observations that
we're really looking forward to it's kind of nice that the crew will get a little break in there
because they have been hitting it hard today with photos and videos and annotations what are you
hoping that the crew sees coming up is it that lunar dust oh my goodness that's a hard question
to answer i mean we've already gotten such great descriptions i mean the terminator seems to just
be like one of their favorite things to look at and describe so i feel like um you know that was
something we were looking forward to i feel like we've really gotten some great descriptions so
absolutely i'm looking to the human moment of earth rise lofted dust is an exciting one and
lofted dust will be a target for them in the right after um right around the time of earth rise but
again in the eclipse period so i'm really looking forward to seeing i mean they've already highlighted
just in the course of their flyby so far how the moon has changed and this is going to be an even
more dramatic change to go from their end of this kind of lunar illuminated piece of
the flyby into the eclipse time frame and I can tell you they're going to be experiencing
a very different moon during that time and I can't wait to hear what their observations
are.
Yeah that's absolutely fascinating and what a what a privilege that we get to do that
on this mission because that's not always the case if we had launched on a different
day other than April 1st or 2nd we wouldn't have gotten to see that eclipse is that right?
That's correct.
April 1st and 2nd, I will say, you know, I was asked a lot in the weeks leading up to
the launch, well, what's your favorite day?
And my answer truly was there is no bad day to launch to the moon.
We were going to get great science out of it no matter what.
But it's a really neat opportunity to, you know bring the sun into the picture, bring
different planetary bodies into the picture while still literally keeping the moon in
center stage.
Fascinating.
So what differences are we looking for at each site?
We're hearing a lot of different terms.
We're looking at craters.
Looking at MARE, what are the differences that you're hoping to see?
We do have, as you highlight, kind of different prompts for each target.
That's what they're looking at in their lunar targeting plan, which I know you've been showing.
And we have even different prompts for the person with the, you know, the really long
lens on the camera versus the people with the unaided eye.
And you've heard the crew talk about, oh, my goodness, when I go from one to the other,
I can really detect different nuances.
And that's something that we experienced in simulations, but hearing them actually, you
know see it for real has been really gratifying but we're looking for
different things based on the target sometimes we're looking
for color sometimes we're
looking for texture for the Terminator we're looking at kind of what texture
and morphologies pop out to you and what kind of diversity you see along the
Terminator you've heard you know Victor especially make some comments about
future impacts for exploration so already I think that their descriptions
in this first part of the flyby have told us something scientifically but
also about future surface missions. Well, oh, it was so interesting to hear Victor talking about
he was imagining in his mind's eye being down on the surface and walking around. That was
very cool to hear. And when we're thinking about targets, I know some of them are determined based
on the launch day because that determines the lunar illumination. So the ones that we're looking
at today, how and why were these selected? Such a wonderful question. This really gets at some,
like at the heart of some of our really highest priority science questions illumination conditions
is a big one right so of course we need the targets that we're interested on the lunar
feature to be illuminated by the sun in order to view them but the timing in which they see
them during the flyby enables us to ask different questions so you heard in the pre-flyby crew
conference talking about well the same pair reed and jeremy will get to actually look at glushko
crater twice and that looking at it from different illumination angles allows us to understand that
feature better and connect color and albedo with topography and morphology.
Then you have other craters where you want to look at it with the sun shining on it obliquely
versus straight on and that tells you something different about the scientific objective that
drove the target being on the targeting plan in the first place. We've talked a little bit
with the viewers today about how what the crew is able to capture in this short time frame
Of those craters in different lighting conditions could take years for something robotic to be able
to do based on attitude maneuvers and where the sun is at. So can you just talk a little bit about
the importance of having both the robotic operation and having the crew? Absolutely.
We definitely don't want to minimize the impact of orbiting spacecraft. Lunar Reconnaissance
Orbiter is one that's often referenced. Data from LRO and its payloads have really been
instrumental in getting us, frankly, to this point for Artemis II and future missions.
But the human experience, the crew observations that we've already been hearing about,
it is such a perfect complement to the orbiting spacecraft data because they are able to have
this unique perspective. They are far enough away where they can make these contextual
observations. You've already heard it. How many times have we heard the crew
and their science sit reps say, if I track this feature from all the way up here in the
northern hemisphere down to the southern hemisphere, here are comparisons I can make?
That right there is not something we had the ability to do with the Apollo missions, and it allows just literally in the blink of an eye to synthesize observations that it would take, you know, a really significant effort to coordinate with different orbiting platforms, and they're making it like that.
Wow. It has been very, very exciting to hear all of their calls so far, and so I've heard they were able to capture every single target so far, too. Is that correct?
I think that's correct. And I think it's important also to remember that, and I know the science team is anxiously awaiting this, we've been hearing from the crew members who are not at the forward windows, right? Those crew who are, you know, really in the thick of the observations, they are recording minutes-long observations per target on their crew tablets.
We will be getting those down starting here in a couple hours, and that's going to contain really meaty science information that we haven't heard live yet, and that is going to form the basis of my conversation with them tomorrow morning where we're going to have a really deep dive into the science and absolutely nerd out about what they were able to do today.
One of the most gratifying things for me today is hearing multiple crew members say, thank you for putting the discussion times in the targeting plan, because when we have had the ability to put multiple brains on a problem, we have elevated each other, and I'm looking forward to them, you know, sleeping on it overnight, and then us actually being able to really truly have an elevated science discourse tomorrow.
Well, we're looking forward to it, too. And I cannot wait to hear everything that you guys get to learn overnight from some of those audio recordings and just everything that they'll be able to share tomorrow.
So, Kelsey, I know you are very busy. You've done a great job today. And thank you so much for joining us for this interview.
Thanks for having me. It's such an exciting day.
We are now expecting acquisition of signal in about 24 minutes.
As a reminder, the Orion spacecraft has flown around the other side of the Moon where they
are out of contact with our deep space network.
And we just heard confirmation here in Mission Control Houston that we have reached the closest
point of our destination to the Moon at MET 5 days, 25 minutes, and 34 seconds.
And we anticipate the spacecraft's altitude is approximately 4,067 statute miles above
the Moon.
We're continuing to track what the crew is doing while around the other side of the moon.
They are continuing to take pictures of the Earth, or sorry, of the moon, the Earth now out of sight.
What they are in right now is a crew choice event.
The science team has encouraged them to find interesting features on the surface,
to take photos of those, and describe why they were interesting.
Something else that they'll be looking toward next, just momentarily, will be impact flashes.
They've got a few minutes allotted to look at the darkest portions of the Moon.
They're interested in short-lived flashes on the lunar surface because these would be
caused by impact bombardment.
After their impact flash targeting, the team is interested in if the crew can see lofted
lunar dust.
This would only be visible just before Earthrise.
Now 20 minutes until we expect to regain communications with integrity
and the astronauts for Artemis II.
We're live in Mission Control Houston at NASA's Johnson Space Center,
but there's a team over 750 miles away also monitoring today's operations.
And of course, just like us, they are in LOS or loss of signal with the spacecraft.
This is LUCA, the Lunar Utilization Control Area, and it's joined by LISA,
the Lander Engineering Support Area, which are twin control rooms
that will support missions and operations in lunar orbit
or on the moon's surface in real time
at NASA's Marshall Space Flight Center in Huntsville, Alabama.
The LUCA and LISA are right next to each other
and just a short walk away
from the SLS Engineering Support Center,
which is used during launch, and the POIC, where science
on the International Space Station is monitored.
LUCA primarily supports Artemis science operations,
while LISA will provide engineering support
for landing astronauts on the moon.
During this mission, Artemis II, teams in the LUCA will use the facility to support
first-of-its-kind science operations to better understand the deep space effects of microgravity
and radiation on the crew's physiology, immune systems, and ability to complete various tasks.
The data from these science operations will inform future crewed flights to the Moon.
For future crewed missions to the Moon, members of the NASA Human Landing System Mission Insights
Support team, a group of engineers, safety leads, flight operations experts and technical
authorities will work in the LISA.
There they will monitor lander systems in real time and be involved in key decision
making processes throughout the mission.
Teams are using the LISA during Artemis II to observe mission operations and using the
opportunity to inform and prepare for future crewed landings to the moon's surface.
We now expect to regain communications with the astronauts aboard Orion in about 17 minutes.
In the meantime, a little overview of how our crew members flying by the lunar far side
at an altitude of between 4,000 and 9,000 miles are testing the capabilities of the
Orion capsule.
Artemis II visualization lead Ernie Wright has simulated views of the flyby using detailed
topographic maps of the lunar terrain and photorealistic lighting scenarios.
The Artemis II crew members have been using these visualizations to prepare for this historic
mission, which is paving the way for future exploration of the moon's surface and beyond.
So the most exciting thing to me about Artemis II is just the return to the moon. We haven't
been there in 50 years. Human eyes are going to see parts of the moon that haven't been seen
by anyone before. It also recommits us to exploring the solar system in a way that we
haven't in a long time. And I think it provides an opportunity for younger generations to
understand the excitement of doing that kind of exploration. Artemis is our return to the moon
after 50 years. The emphasis of Artemis is going to be first of all science, but second of all
learning to sustain a presence on another world. First on the moon, but we're hoping that that's
a stepping stone to Mars and other destinations in the solar system eventually. Artemis 2 will
be a flyby mission. It's not going to land. We're testing all of the technology that we've created
for flying to the moon since Apollo.
A lot of systems have been modernized,
and we need to make sure that all of those work.
The astronauts will be looking out the window
at parts of the moon that have never been seen
by human eyes before.
They will be flying by the moon at an altitude
that's much higher than Apollo's orbits,
and so they will see the entire disk of the moon,
including areas that are closer
to both the North and South Pole
that astronauts from Apollo never saw.
All of that depends on the lighting, which we really won't know until launch day,
but we can practice with different lighting scenarios.
It's hard for people to sort of picture that in their mind.
If you can make a visualization of it, show them a movie,
that helps everybody choose the targets and also practice aiming at those targets.
The astronauts have actually been looking at these visualizations through the lens of the camera
and practicing aiming at the various targets.
This is a map of the surface of the moon obviously but it shows what the Apollo astronauts could see
in sunlight while they were in orbit. The brighter parts are the parts that they could see,
the darker parts like this entire area here and places that are farther north and south
are places that they couldn't see in sunlight either because it was nighttime there or because
it was beyond the horizon of the astronauts. All of the Apollo flights orbited the Moon at a distance
of about 110 kilometers. Because the astronauts were flying at such a low altitude, their horizon
was actually quite close and they couldn't see the north and south poles. And this whole area over
here was not in sunlight at the time. And it includes this amazing impact feature here called
oriental oriental is a very large impact feature it's about 650 kilometers wide it's got multiple
rings these are rings that form like ripples in a pond from the impact but of course it's on a huge
scale the middle of oriental has that sort of dark basalt lava covering it like the dark spots that
we see on the near side it's one of the biggest ones that's more on the far side than near so
seeing it with human eyes and sort of picking out features that maybe you don't even see
in robotic cameras is an important goal for the mission this live view in the silent science
evaluation room or the sir here at johnson space center in houston texas just down the hall from
where we're at in the artemis mission control room teams continuing to monitor the flyby
the crew continues their observations of the moon even though they are out of touch with earth we
expect to hear from them in 12 minutes and 26 seconds. Again this is
approximately 40 minutes loss of signal while they are out of reach of the deep
space network. Right now they are imaging or attempting to image lofted lunar dust.
Throughout our coverage we've talked a lot about the science and engineering
behind today's lunar flyby but we also spoke to the crew about what the
moon means to them and how they see its place in human history.